oh yeah i'm [ __ ] burnt marty
i am a bird
[Music]
what's up guys sorry what's up this is
the dope as usual podcast i'm your host
obaziola today we are here
to talk about life problems
accomplishments drugs and everything in
between
today we have very funny comedian
jessica paluso thank you
very much for coming today
no i laughed because you were so
professional and we were just ripping
[ __ ] for like
20 minutes it's customer service hello
welcome to the dogo's yola podcast i am
your host that just threw me off i tried
i tried i used to do the pizza phone
like oh hello
[ __ ] this [ __ ] oh hello you know what
i'm saying did you ever have a retail
job like that i did i worked at h
m for like five or six years god i know
retail is retail's the worst
retail's the worst because you can have
a day in one day and see
a doctor in his scrubs jerk off into
brown coordinates
stop stop and then also have a woman in
the fitting room leave
[ __ ] in a bag that's a tuesday at retail
shop the second one i understand
please explain the first that happened
what do you mean a doctor in the scrubs
jerked off into what
into like these brown coordinates not
even the nice
color clothes given it was fall so i
understand the choice of color
scheme but it was midday i was in
downtown crossing
and i was in the back of the store
perfect pov of everything going on
and i see this doctor in blue scrubs
come up and stand
you know clothing racks yeah he's
standing into it
and like why is this guy he's having
like a senior moment he's just standing
staring
he no oh [ __ ] he was like a very
attractive
oh [ __ ] like doctor i would have
considered
until i i saw this a jerking movement
and i was like
oh he's seizing out i'm like i always
see the good in people yeah
you know really oh maybe his arm season
i'm like oh he's he's nervous
no he was jerking off into the clothing
now you tell as a man
no no that's a creep that's creep [ __ ]
right there's nothing in my head that
goes you know what i [ __ ] do today
what fetish is that
fall also yeah yo this is what i do in
autumn
because it was like brown turtlenecks
that he was jerking
you know what it was he wanted to do it
so when someone gets they go oh
and him at home there might be something
to that has to be
he's like the little kid used to wipe
his snot places oh my god it has to be
you know where that [ __ ] happens the
most and people don't realize it like i
feel like we all need like microscopic
tools and is in new york city because
there's so many people
and so many walks of life on the train
system
like i saw a homeless woman here's
another gross story hey guys i'm dressed
i'm here to talk about my foods it's so
good
this so i go to get on the train it's
like midnight and i get on and i look to
the left and the whole train like all
these people are shoved in the left side
someone's doing something and i went to
go to the right and they went no no no
no no
like as a collective they're like come
over here and stand with us
and i look to the right and there's one
homeless woman naked
a rather zaftig woman
large large woman naked at the end of
the train taking her hand
wiping her biscuit and spreading it
everywhere
the baby [ __ ] dry wiping her biscuit
and just doing a broad stroke like a
basquiat
on the oh i know it's hilarious
it's still funny it's just that she was
disgusting so the moral of the story
love your children is the moral of the
story love your children let them know
they're loved
don't take molly and ecstasy and acid
together
don't don't because you're gonna lose
your pants and your puss juice on
the l train [ __ ] i'm so sorry
that's okay i've seen something i've
seen some [ __ ] i've seen some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but
damn i saw speaking of homeless naked
people
i was driving on i was all right let's
say i wasn't driving i was on snapchat
in a vehicle that was moving that was
moving and i saw
so many business people downtown just
stopped on the corner nah
something happened go a little farther i
see a bunch of cops with their hands the
force gumping it like this just standing
there
they weren't doing [ __ ] like this yep
and then
halfway up the thing up the street
there's a homeless black dude completely
naked
with the [ __ ] newspaper stand over
his head like he's like
and he's ripping [ __ ] out and then what
made me
really like just die laughing is because
i realized
why they didn't want to touch this man
raging
erection this fool's dick was like 19
[ __ ] inches down his leg and
every time he moved he was flopping like
crazy
and he could see all these cops like i'm
not taking it to the face today oh i
want to say what a waste of dick
but what a waste of money what a waste
of good girth
you know not to say that the men i've
dated in my past have all had homes
i mean like most of them claim to but
who am i
especially in la i can't tell who's
homeless
they all look homeless here with their
buns and their pitbulls and their
bicycles and tents
five o'clock shadow or i don't sleep in
the inside
yeah oh my god you just explained echo
park yeah exactly it's silver lake
that's
all of it yeah silver lake is santa cruz
of l.a
it truly is more gang bangers here but
that's about it
so you said you grew up in new york are
you born and raised i was born and
raised in syracuse new york
yeah a really like working class
blue collar area you know uh
running around in the streets as a kid
and just
coming home when the when the street
lights came on like such a great
quintessential
american upbringing where there was no
cell phones there were no computers
we if there was a show you [ __ ]
showed up sure it's
oh it's a dirty [ __ ] gotta get home we
gotta get home tgif is on
it's fri remember tjf of course oh we
were just talking about this last
episode
friday night you [ __ ] don't even know
friday night programming
was something it was the sh i got
gushers and [ __ ] sunny d
yes let's go and cheetos you're like man
i used to [ __ ] with cheetos heavy
yeah i watched roseanne heavy i watched
all that [ __ ] but
were you a cartoon network kid or nick
oh man that's a really
really dividing question very polarizing
i might just say nickelodeon same here
cartoon network is a hit and miss
it really was a hit and miss it wasn't
consistent but like nickelodeon wasn't
there like
that what was that show where green
slime would come down it's lime time
live
i went one time i love that i didn't
even finish the question you're like
slime time life
oh yeah i had a season pass my mom was a
such a dick and that was one of the few
things she did she said we're going to
the dance go
[ __ ] [ __ ] and she dropped us off
what the [ __ ] is this place they open
the door and it was nickelodeon filming
and she drove off go
i [ __ ] with you now this is what yes oh
what was the remember the host the white
dude hello that guy that would pick
kids he did this to me picking kids went
yo
he picked the kid next to me my sister
and i've hated him ever since
oh that's terrible he literally went
like that
no you were the kids that he picked
white they were
of course this is this is a problem in
america
this you were robbed of a dream that's
right of a dream in social media
rude where did you grow up merced
california
it's um that sounds that sounds fancy as
[ __ ] oh it's not
it's four hours north it's a you ever
seen the vice documentaries on meth
yeah that's merced i was i was a star oh
[ __ ]
speaking i had a role i'm better now
i'm still crying from the large [ __ ]
man who had the newspaper thing over
here
that had to be meth or crack what's the
drug that gives you like
so much energy pcp it's nasty
is it have you done it have you done all
drugs
i've never done heroin crack smoke crack
cocaine smoke coke boof
it's not drunk i'm just trying to trick
you
or acid either you haven't have not i'm
assumed shrooms
i [ __ ] love mushrooms i definitely
assume shrooms i i take them every
single day do you really like i do i
microdose
i put them in you know i have this um
tea that i drink
because i can't drink coffee anymore
it's called mud water and it already has
mushrooms in it
but not like the fun fun kind but still
really good mushrooms
wait is this a thing this is a thing i'm
way into adaptogens
huge huge huge rishi chaga lions main
ashwagandha
i take it every day for calm and focus
and this mud water [ __ ] that i drink is
amazing but then i'll also put
real mushrooms in it like still diving
tablets
yeah like like tablets i'll crack open
the gel tab and i'll sprinkle
a little bit of the mushrooms into the
mushroom tea and then i'm like golden
who needs a doctor
i'm living life without any
pharmaceuticals
[ __ ] at that point therapist is right
here
it's the therapist in a cup that's true
people don't realize that uh
mushrooms are the the future they really
are i mean they're the past the present
and the future
they don't understand yet people get so
scared they do because it's scary
sometimes
i've had trips where i forgot where i
was but
it was that's what i was going for yeah
it's interesting how like
drugs i i definitely i'm sure you do
consider i consider it more medicine
than a drug like marijuana and mushrooms
i call everything a drug
and then when somebody else calls a drug
it's not a [ __ ] drug exactly
you get all defensive like it's your kid
yeah don't talk about my kid that one
[ __ ]
well the difference between i think
things like shrooms and marijuana is the
next couple of days
yes you know where there isn't
necessarily a recovery
there's no recovery off weed unless you
just don't smoke a lot and then that's
called sleep
yeah or you got fat as [ __ ] but you were
lazy before you smoked weed i love when
people like weed makes you lazy nah
[ __ ] you were lazy first
i do a lot of [ __ ] while smoking weed
[ __ ] it's you
yeah i get you i mean hello
get [ __ ] done uh hello
we're busy you are the quintessential
example
of getting high and smoking i'm doing a
successful stoner
thank you and it's it's just i think now
like the stigma is being
evolved as people realize the benefit of
the plant
yeah but there's still people who are
like oh oh were you just
you're smoking weed all day yeah and i'm
getting [ __ ] done yes and i'm getting
things done it's not like i'm like
i haven't smoked it's three o'clock it's
more of i smoke weed right now yeah
it's never like i need it because i'll
go all day sometimes if i forget
because i'm busy but it's not like i
need to
no but i do a lot you're probably not an
addict
i'm just assuming addicted but it's it's
my friend
have you ever been addicted to anything
um i had about three weeks where i'm
like you know me and coke go well
together
you know but i meant to go for years but
there was a few weeks where i went hey
slow that [ __ ] down
you just sold your playstation
i was like you sold your playstation no
for
money and then i went back well i mean
essentially yeah like
that but once you go trade for drugs
is it the last time you did that traded
for drugs yeah i mean i always had a job
i was like my chick don't [ __ ] god
it's friday [ __ ] it's a slippery slope
it's a slippery slope bad i've seen i've
seen people sell everything
from merced it's like home of meth so
i've seen people sell i believe it man
and that's like
for me that's why i haven't done
anything other than like
you've never done hard drugs i've never
done hard drugs
because i i know myself it's it's scary
right it's such a slippery slope
you have you have that one family member
you're like yeah they're here uncle john
no i'm just kidding love you uncle john
that was my uncle john too made him do
drugs all right
we did drugs forever was a straight edge
but i just thought it was funny
he never did coke and then i got him on
i was 15 he was 26 and i'll never do
coke
i'm like are you sure we were drunk
drinking milk high lives
that was it it's miller highlights
oh keystone light goes with
every hard drug you can think of oh my
god it's like bloodlight goes with
domestic abuse just the way another life
goes with
hardcore trucks it's really tough
we probably should
[Laughter]
that's great he might change he might
not and it's going to be dope as usual
right next to it
remember those [ __ ] ads i love those
ads
even as a kid like just [ __ ] leave
you remember the ad
this is your brain this is your braid on
drugs what
a delicious breakfast yes it never got
me even as a kid that never dare program
didn't [ __ ] me up
no nothing nothing scared me nothing
scared me either i feel like your own
experience is gonna be your experience
crack i'm good you seem like try it
or don't but that's it yeah if you've
never done hard drugs
keep it the way i agree they're so
[ __ ] fun
i know and it's like i feel ironically
like the war on drugs
sort of really affected people's usage
of them
yes like i really feel if we just
eradicated that moment in history
was his name henry s esslinger who was
the guy who created the dea
ignorant i don't know what the dude who
sort of
put this whole thing in straight up yeah
the [ __ ] party pooper
for real national party poop lose
her debbie downer we'll call him debbie
downer i feel like if that whole thing
didn't happen in the whole war on drugs
with reagan and everything like
i feel like maybe we would have had a
little bit
easier of a time and people maybe
wouldn't have overused not to say that
there aren't people who obviously access
them
yeah to satisfy an addiction but i
really feel like the usage would have
been completely different
yeah because people i have access i
don't like it yeah i'm good
it's like the reverse psychology it's
the no you can't date this girl oh my
dear
oh i need to get her you're like oh no
you can't have any of this puss and then
they want it
so bad brad pitt i'm great
is he single or something well
angelina's taking him to the cleaners
angelina jolie yeah they're going to
divorce court now and she's like would
she have more money
right like what what i thought she was
way more bald than brad pitt
why is she taking well she wants
everyone to think he's like a domestic
abuser and i will not accept it doubt
that you ever seen
true romance where he's just getting
high the [ __ ] honey bottle
he was so great in that he is not a
domestic abuser he doesn't like bud
light
he wants to be cuddled i bet he's a
cuddler
postcoitus oh my god he's worth 300
look at that face he's got a face only a
mother could sit
on it's so beautiful
you're not even wrong i am that's the
most sad after man on the [ __ ] planet
beautiful he dated that like russian
chick who was in an open relationship
did you know that
no she's like this gorgeous 27 year old
who
dated this man who was well she was
married to like a 67 year old
wax face and they had an open
relationship look at this beautiful
russian chick she's so
that look at her husband it looks like
he does art at a community college
that's art he teaches art and gets in
his kia and drives the [ __ ] off
damn brad pitt you're getting he does
pottery at ucla look at her
they dated for a weekend for a weekend i
really thought i had a chance and i saw
this [ __ ] i'm like oh he's got a pose
like that
damn like no one's there who's your
celebrity crush
as a kid or now oh wow i mean we i feel
like we should do
all of it as a kid i don't know what the
[ __ ] it was
i loved julia styles so much as a kid
and now i grew up like julia styles but
it's so specific was it because i like
10 things they hate about you like yo
she's tired
she's not like the other girls this is
sick because i [ __ ] hated girls
growing up because merced is full of
dumb [ __ ]
ah i just i despise
like growing up my mom was one of those
dumb [ __ ] so really
wow that's a that's a large statement
she knows we talk about it a lot
no my mom my mom is just like i am she
knows she owns it
do you guys go to therapy [ __ ] no
no that's what these are for texas here
you go
no hell no hey [ __ ] there's a time
where we both got really upset at each
other but
um no there's no therapy no you gotta
pay for that [ __ ] i know
i know that's that's the crazy part i
feel like that needs to be evolved as
well
if it's free and i get out of class i'm
going to therapy yeah i mean
why wouldn't we have that be accessible
everything
when you look at it as an adult and
obviously you know social media and news
is so
controlled by different corporations
that have
ulterior motives but when you stand back
and look at the bigger picture you're
like
oh oh you want to make drugs illegal the
good ones the fun ones but then the ones
that are really bad
i can get from my doctor and when i go
crazy
it's not easily accessible it's it's the
same guy that sells you the pills is the
same guy that tells you to go to the
therapist and the same guy
that does it all like i always say the
guy that makes coca-cola does not
[ __ ] drink it
because he knows like that [ __ ] you know
what's in there
don't drink i know it's it's so good
though that crisp coca-cola with crushed
ice
and and like roller rink pizza do you
remember
roller rink pizza i remember the smell
of that [ __ ]
oh man remember roller land was our spot
merced
okay let's do a game go describe one
one word to describe the smell of the
roller rink
on the count of three one two
three perverted
[Laughter]
how close that [ __ ] was not
planned at all that's how i might go
someone's a [ __ ] pedophile i was like
someone got fingered in here
something next perverted fingering
that's exactly what it smelled like
21 year old picking up on 15 year old
girls that's what it smells like
it smells like touchy uncles a g uncle
that's a good ass rap man they will not
be at coachella this year
is coachella going to be at coachella
this year michelle is going to be
separated
you're going to have to be in your own
little spot everyone has their own
bonfire and tiki hut
you know what they probably will and
sell you at the highest price you've
ever paid and you're gonna pay it
because i haven't been anywhere
it's ridiculous i'll pay fifty dollars
to go watch a [ __ ] [ __ ] movie at the
theaters right now they're starting to
open them
amc is opening ninety percent of their
theaters state uh countrywide
that's all i ever do that's my thing
like you wanna get belligerently [ __ ]
up in the parking lot and then walk in
that's my favorite thing in life homie
you know what you need what you need the
wine bra
this shit's on amazon and it's the
greatest thing oh it's a bra that's a
plastic bag and you can fill it with
wine
think they're gonna be like hey young
man
do you have tits on that's what i'm
saying they won't ask you that
that's a hate crime true true they can't
they can't they can't gender eyes you
i'll wear a violet femme shirt and go i
think that's that's a girl i'm not gonna
you wear a tight tight crop top and
you're a wine bra
i got one for the for the movie theaters
i'd rather just watch netflix
i'm not gonna go through all that or
i've i've snuck in entire sandwiches
into this oh hell yeah yeah so
because you're a smart man i'll bring
liquor i bring every i bring a whole
this is really embarrassing rotisserie
chicken i feel like that's what you're
gonna say next
i don't know i'm gonna jump the gun
a whole rotisserie chicken
oh that's a shape of a chicken from safe
mart
that's the [ __ ] it is i'm not wrong i'm
crying no
it's going to say a whole bag of [ __ ]
you bring popcorn
wait you have to cook it first it's
inflated
cook it move over gordon ramsay coming
to nbc this fall
dope is yola in the kitchen cooking
popcorn you said you have to cook it
you have to no one cooks popcorn yeah
you eat this [ __ ] up
it's no cooking it's just
wait how do you bring about oh like
chips when they leave them at trader
joe's the bags
because i was thinking you have to
inflate that [ __ ] first
i have an air popper
and you're like yeah and so you bring a
whole bag
inside i do bring a whole bag inside and
i don't [ __ ] around
you know what i make the pop i cook the
popcorn at home
see you do cook popcorn i do cook it i
put it in a big-ass plastic bag with
some olive oil
a little bit of natural yeast and some
himalayan salt
yeah every day what did i call it you
said i think natural but not good yeah
yeah
most people don't know what nutritional
yeast is i thought you're just saying it
nationally
east from america no it's just good
it's so good and i hide it in my bag i
just put it in a bag
like a diaper bag and i don't have a kid
but they're like where's your kid i'm
like i don't know
he's in there but he's in the theater so
i got his diapers in here it's just
popcorn
it's actually dirty [ __ ] diaper yeah you
want to see no
you did they asked can you see your bag
oh you bastard
with the sandwiches the downtown amc uh
taco bell
oh come on [ __ ] i feel like you
should be able to bring taco bell
in it's flat it's flat nobody gives a
[ __ ] it's this big
yo you've never been caught of all the
years that's no good i am white
white people get caught we just don't
get accused
we get caught and we get like you know
naps everything he just says
you don't get accused but if we get
caught the person goes [ __ ] i have to
i have to take you in
yeah i got caught once no i smoke a weed
in the parking lot and the security came
out and
like hounded me for my id says if you're
above 18
i'll let you stay and go i'm driving a
car
i'm pretty sure i'm [ __ ] 18. i have a
full head of hair i'm a grown man
exactly and he bugged me and he made me
leave i mean no
he called the cops so i left for 20
minutes came back and watched the movie
that's just so
there's so many other things going on in
society that need attention
other than teenagers can we go to the
[ __ ] movies two cars in the parking
lot
movie like come on bro you guys need the
business
please let me just go ahead this is a
statistical game at this point what are
we doing i don't know he followed me
into the theater
i'm gonna open a movie theater we should
open a movie theater together where
there's a hot box room
oh my god and a room instead of those
balls you know those balls you jump into
it's all cheetah cheez-its and you scoot
you jump in you scoop them this is a
scrooge
duck a dream you have right now a bunch
of jesus
that sounds poor i also was in a moving
vehicle on the way here and there was
weed in it
i wasn't driving the car oh that's fine
but i don't enjoy the tesla beamer
yeah that's fine the second i light [ __ ]
my car drives itself
yeah it's fine a tesla beamer tesla
beamer
what the [ __ ] i mean movies and weed go
hand in hand they should have a theater
showing horror movies and they hotbox
the entire theater
you don't like horror movies oh god i
was just talking about who the [ __ ] are
they just talking about this i just talk
about i have to put my lipstick on for
this
you hate hormones are you hold on
is the lipstick going to help yeah i
want to know it's going to help
my lipstick it's going to help me in
this scenario absolutely yeah
wait i just don't like my thing is that
fear you get in
in horror movies like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] i always explain it as
walking to school like gamer said like i
have that fear like i don't know a woman
more of it
going to my car it's so scary
thinking about it i i walk around at all
times waiting to
[ __ ] fight somebody when in a parking
lot i couldn't imagine like
you're trying to penetrate me too oh my
god could you imagine
every guy out there think about it what
if you get raped
girls think about that every five
seconds every five seconds and i'm so
glad that you
said this because it's something i talk
about in my stand up where men
don't have to consider that factor you
don't have to be
worried about also getting raped or
penetrated
or whatever like it's not sure you might
get robbed and murdered
but some of those things happen happen
and that's just the way it goes but
women also have to
you know at night check our showers to
make sure nobody's in there
i know i'm not the only [ __ ] that does
that i do it every time i walk in my
house do you
i always assume there's somebody waiting
to rob me in my house
i think the same except change the rob
for rape
yeah it's the same it's interchangeable
i always usually say that folks trying
to steal sex and people got real mad at
me about it
trying to steal sex it's better than
saying rape like he's a sex thief like
what do you mean a rapist can i say that
in my stand up i will totally credit you
but it's funnier though it's a better
way of saying rape yeah it's stealing
sex that's exactly what's going
on that's scary it is scary that's real
[ __ ] because i
what was it was that a song about uh i
always feel like someone's watching me
as a kid sometimes i think
somebody's watching me nice i like it
thank you for knowing the song
i love that phone and there's just like
a guy who comes out of your refrigerator
how to get in there we don't know
i check under my cabinets oh yeah i
don't blame you
sixth sense [ __ ] me up hell yeah each
patient came in he was all
tripping to shoot him yes mark wahlberg
on meth
i don't want that in my [ __ ] kitchen
that was mark wahlberg
yeah or donnie one of the ones probably
donnie because he definitely lost a
couple of the attractive genes
i think mark sucked it all up in utero
it was him
yeah wow he lost a lot of weight for
that oh yeah
he was great small role didn't lose
no you're going to shoot somebody and
everybody hates you
it's a small role to lose all that
weight can you imagine though
i mean i know a lot of tweakers that do
that [ __ ] too i know they could just you
know what
i'm offended that they're not hiring
actual meth addicts
we need to stand up against hollywood
oh you gotta hire you can't hire a real
meth addict you got to go and cast one
scarlett johansson is not a real meth
addict
oh my god i just went through
how many movies of like yo if they
really got real people
real crackheads and [ __ ] new jacks
aviation oh yeah could you imagine how
long it would take to film that [ __ ]
like yo where's the crackheads
do you think i [ __ ] know where the
crackheads are all at craft services
not eating [ __ ] they're just panhandling
stealing it all and selling it back to
the production crew i've had people i've
i gave crackheads stuff before and i've
literally watched them try this i gave
this
i give weed away in downtown because
it's like you need it
yeah that's where i've been slept for
years to crack kids especially yo here's
some wii
i had a woman i gave her i gave her like
a
20 sack of weed my hair smoke it up and
she goes
what about a dollar and i went you can
go sell that to somebody and get a
dollar she goes oh yeah yeah and she
walked away like
damn was she new to the game she was
like 60.
[ __ ] how long she been homeless i mean
she got to figure out she's got to
figure out the hustle
she needs to figure something i mean
weed is that's something that's a
commodity on the street still i would
assume
i do the same thing i give weed to
homeless people too it's
i ain't gonna give you money you might
spend it on drugs but if they're super
not we're just talking about this if
they're super nice i'll give them money
yeah there's a vibe you could sense and
you can sense like is this woman
just or man using the system or are they
actually a product of the system yeah
and that's where you
like it's uh it's an energy thing one
day i was coming back from
the pancake house which is a place i
think in missouri i thought you were
just being fancy of ihop right now no
did you i was at the house of pancakes
internationally um
it's a very it's basically the ritz
carlton of pancakes no it's actually
called the pancake
pancake pantry i can't think of where it
is people listening but if anybody's
from the town it's a great place
and i had a bunch of pancakes and i gave
it to a homeless dude is that a weird
thing to give to a homeless dude [ __ ]
i'm getting hell pancakes from the
pantry
downtown to homeless people i've done
that yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah i know
there was this dude that slept across
the street i used to live at the met
downtown by uh the staples center
downtown here is downtown here is an is
a video game
thank you i always say that it's like
gta and half the people are avatars
and they're just walking until you talk
to them yes i'm telling you it really is
like it's like it's like
sims and zombies every store front has a
fake name water shirts [ __ ]
you ever seen one downtown shirts
embroidery like [ __ ] that's just not
real
what store are you going to share stores
i'm telling you there's there's in
orange county especially
yeah all these are fronts there's a
place called okay water you ever seen
that
i mean is it next to better water i'd go
to bed
i don't know if they know they spelled
their name cocaine but it says cocaine
something but it's in another language
it says [ __ ] cocaine on the building
i don't know if they know like
a picture of that i 100 did it to my
phone you've got to post that [ __ ] i
just don't want people to know where i'm
at oh that's true i know you said that
when we walked in guys we are at once i
was going to buy
smith lane through fake street
no um a lot of those places downtown are
just
they're so bad it is strange
unbelievable like the downtown area in
la because i lived in new york city for
10 years and
how was that amazing amazing the
greatest experience of my life
especially for your 20s there's just
when did you move there i moved there
when i was 23.
from boston i went from syracuse to
boston and then to new york city and it
was just
it was such an amazing experience
because it opened me up to so many
cultures that i wasn't already
introduced to or had knowledge of i mean
luckily where i grew up in syracuse
it was a very diverse culture there was
a lot of different
ethnicities where i grew up in new york
yeah in syracuse and people don't they
don't
realize that it's a very diverse um more
than society
right i think so because we have like
six ethnic towns like
little italy's little types of whites
and then everyone else is shoved into
one little area
yeah if they're if they look kind of
aggressive like always russian
yeah scares the
you have to separate the whites because
if they're wearing
pumas and some kind of high water
they're from europe
absolutely europeans love pumas i
[ __ ] just
i don't get it they love pumas they love
those like zip up like
adidas jackets with the little side
pockets
yeah yes they all look like they run
like a boxing gym
in philly they look like speaking of
brad pitt they like
snatch like they have that [ __ ] that's
exactly what they all look oh god
it goes right back to brad pitt drip
drop in 2021
oh drip drop
that's why my mom married [ __ ] my st
it's a long story my mom
your mom married brad pitt no she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] for sure
no she's a it's a long story
mom was married to a genuine genuine
white supremacist for about eight years
straight and i know it's
sounds dumb it's legitimate as [ __ ] but
he looked just like brad pitt
and the reason why is because we were
watching american
history reaction they go mom you're in
love with edward norton he's a he's a
nazi in this movie
i just got [ __ ] chills because
anybody who hasn't seen american history
x
and edward norton in that movie and you
think that that is not a depiction of
what's going on in this country
you've got another thing coming yeah he
started off real nice
really cool hey my dad's a firefighter
now i hate everyone i mean
look at edward i mean that is just so
terrifying your mom was married to that
guy
i mean theoretically um a scarier
version of that guy
why why but he was mad chill mad cool
yes
to us it's a long story in jail it's
different he explained it to me when i
got older i was like in jail because my
best friend's black and his dad's
the share of the detective of our town
and he's a monster
i smell a new netflix series with your
life
because there's so much information that
i'm absorbing your mom being married to
american and my mom's jewish
yeah i'm shorting out yeah it's so dumb
what
it's so dumb my mom's she's a dummy
i just i actually interviewed my mom
like why is she dumb
because she married a [ __ ] nazi why
did she marry a nazi
she liked him and she said what kind of
made my mom mad like it would make
six million people mad i can't say
anything
i don't know if you know what i'm
referring to mom but there was a thing
in the 40s that happened
there's so many millions of people who
will never be mad again ever
jesus christ yeah she married him he was
the [ __ ]
i loved him he was awesome he was so
cool you know he loved us
but did he ever bring his work home with
him
i [ __ ] hope not yeah a few times he
just shows up with a loosey bat and
you're like uh
i did my homework i've been i've we
can't talk about everything when he dies
one day
or he's in prison for life then i'll say
it because she's not married anymore
but the second he's gone and i can't
[ __ ] up his
life yes i understand that but i think
you should start taking notes now
and write the book i have them all in my
head i remember but yes my mom's dumb
anyway she uh she married that guy and i
remember watching american history
reaction like
looking at him looking at him like you
[ __ ]
is this why you married a human because
you're like a
different guy that doesn't even act like
that in real life
right and that's that there's got to be
some aspect of that
where it just boils down to tribalism
for groups
it it's got to be just feeling loved
feeling validated feeling like you're
heard
and also feeling like you're a part of
something i am in no way shape or form
condoning white supremacy no i'm talking
about people being a part of a
a radical group where people go why
would they how could they
because a lot of people are [ __ ] lost
and they can't think for themselves and
they want to belong
that's the main that's the main thing
and you think about how the army
recruits people
people how do you think white
supremacists recruit people i mean hello
jehovah's witness show up at your door
in a nice suit in a book
same [ __ ] it's the same same [ __ ] you
get people that go
hey you like this well i don't like it
oh you know i don't like it either oh
you're on my group now then we gotta not
like it together yep well you're on my
group today
right so here's our doctrine and we all
suck the tit of our doctrine and this is
how we're gonna live
it's how it work did you ever play
sports i did okay so your teammates yes
same thing
same thing except the difference with
like the sports i played in like white
supremacy is i don't know if white
supremacists
start to all cycle together i don't
think they all get their period at the
same time
if they do that must really [ __ ] up the
cloaks
we don't want to get red on those
because they're pure white oh my god
that would really [ __ ] up the [ __ ] up
everything it would [ __ ] up the vibe did
you ever see
django django am i saying it right
django i don't know there's a d
in there i'll just say django that's
django okay yeah don't remember the clan
scene
it really really lightened it up i
really like it well it was just
that's a way of i feel like quinton just
being like these were just
[ __ ] idiots humans stupid mothers why
are we giving them so much power they're
just puppies that are lost looking for
teeth to suck and the teat just happens
to be racism yes
exactly and put it this way they're too
scared to take their hoods off no
of course of course they are because
they have to like show them where they
are
if you walk the walk and walk the talk
and live the life
you don't need a hood you don't need a
mask there's nothing to hide or protect
it's um am i screaming because i'm like
compassionate
it's like it's the gang banger [ __ ]
cause like uh me i'm from merced it's
[ __ ] gang town
but i never joined no gang only because
my mom would punch me in the face and
she told me that every day
so i see other people now that i used to
be friends with as kids and their
[ __ ] just daddy hella gang bangered
out
they're still like yo what's up man no i
don't want to hang out but good to see
you
you know like i don't need you asking me
for favors and i go to jail because of
some stupid [ __ ]
but it's uh i imagine you're your
parents aren't home
and you're by yourself and the kids next
door beat the [ __ ] out of you and then
these kids at school were like no if
we'll hang out with us
tagging crews become gangs well turnkey
kids it's so fast
and it's the same way where we were
talking about like
women needing to be sort of privy to
their surroundings
people who are predatorial know that
know that
and they pick up on those subtle nuances
of somebody who's lost
yeah there was this like study they did
i forget
what company but they took out a bunch
of
convicted felons and set them on a park
bench and they simulated people walking
by
and they asked the the convicted felons
to pick out the people who had
suffered some sort of trauma and were
like vulnerable people who you know like
maybe a woman who had a battered
relationship
or a man who lost a lot or you know
people who suffered a lot
and these individuals who were convicted
were able to
pick out by the way these people walked
people don't realize that like
we carry so much of our trauma with us
yes yeah
i could see i know exactly that's why
women we got to put our tits out in our
chin up when we go through the parking
lot
like come for me yeah come for me my
chin is up [ __ ] it's scary
it's so i'm not even a girl i make sure
i know where i'm parking
listen there's too many columns to hide
behind
[ __ ] that [ __ ] this is scary have you
ever seen cobra with cesar stallone
all right well that girl she did not
have any kind of sense
i need to watch it now it's so bad but
it's so good and it's like
i attribute a lot of that like the way
women carry themselves to us
like the same way society tells men to
be tough society tells women to be nice
you got to be nice smile say thank you
and all this [ __ ] no [ __ ]
no the [ __ ] i don't i need to be smart
dude just creeps too how would you
can't be nice and smile but guys can be
nice and smile something's wrong
yes absolutely it's just terror
it is a terrifying thing as a woman
that's why it's just important i think
to
develop yourself and and figure out your
strength from within so that you carry
yourself in a certain fashion so you
don't get
raped in a garage stole your [ __ ]
doesn't get stolen
taken away yeah they're stealing [ __ ]
out here in the streets and it's not
right
i always think about that like when you
see these
shows you're like the rape rapist guy
what does he do
after what yeah what does he order
dinner i was thinking did he go get
food and like go home like well
i'm gonna do a crossword something does
he feed his cat
for sure oh yeah he's got a cat sure
he's got a cat he's got a hairless cat
i [ __ ] hate those [ __ ] they hate
those cats
oh my god can i talk about this premise
on my goal
i have a whole rape chunk i was raped
oh my i have a whole rape chunk i was oh
my god the [ __ ] way you said that
[ __ ] i really hope this camera got that
face
the way you said it was like no no i
have changed in the car the meter's here
that's how you just pronounce that you
just said it like that [ __ ]
it's the best way to do it because i'm
not one to like ease into the lake i
just jump in i let i let
myself acclimate to the temperature so i
just shocked you i apologize
no no no i talked about it on sickler's
pod i
people get mad at me when i say [ __ ]
like that so it's crazy to hear someone
else say it so openly
well i'm a comedian i have to be open
i'm so upset about it upset at me about
it but the way you said it was like
no there's more weed
that's how you said it like it was like
no this is a good thing like
[ __ ] i have weed that's exactly how i
said it yes
and you're like [ __ ]
so you have a rape chunk in your stance
yeah i've
developed it over years because it
happened when i was 16 actually was the
first time i ever had sex that was my
introduction to
my sexual life was rape and so
obviously it was something that affected
me and definitely one of the
driving factors that brought me to stand
up for sure
but you know um talking about it on
stage is so important and sometimes
people get triggered because they
haven't dealt with their own
healing and so women think that this is
an exploitative thing when it's
more of an expressive thing and talking
about
this being an experience as a woman can
help somebody who has girls
as daughters to know that and to raise
them as such
because when we're born and we're
children our journey initially
is the responsibility of two other
injured and traumatized adults
who are carrying their own trauma into
the scenario so unless we sort of break
the chain
through expression then it just
continues
along on this vicious cycle so like i
feel like it's a responsibility
to talk about it especially because i've
prevailed and i've healed and i've done
the therapy and things that i need in
order to survive in society without
carrying this visceral trauma around
because i guarantee you if i was walking
in the park that [ __ ] wouldn't
know
he wouldn't know if that if that
convicted felon had to look at me
he wouldn't know the amount of [ __ ] that
i've carried and and
that's just the difference i think for a
lot of women is learning how to
process all of that it's [ __ ] up
experiences it is
this means you're not supposed to go
through so how's your brain supposed to
develop and
adapt exactly like i my it was stolen
my my my sexuality was stolen so i had
to find a way to
repair it and and and also find a way to
like understand that it wasn't my fault
because when you look at like the
language in society when it comes to
scenarios that happen it's always like
well women need to carry mace and you
have to be smart and you have to take
self-defense courses
what the [ __ ] what about what the men
need to do what about what the parents
of the children need to do
so i got raped and now also it's my
fault
it's my responsibility known kickboxing
like what the [ __ ]
it's true though you should know
kickboxing people will say something's
[ __ ] yeah oh try kickboxing you
shouldn't okay if a guy gets robbed well
you should have had a gun
bro i shouldn't have to be worried about
getting robbed right let's talk about
the issue
it's your fault before your son's a
[ __ ] creep
you know when kids are creeps you're
gonna [ __ ] chop that [ __ ] down in
early childhood because i guarantee
those parents look at them well i'm
worried about this kid right and they
don't want to they don't want to
deal with it are you kidding me there
are parents out there
literally raising children who had birth
defects that cost thousands of dollars
and have to have all these specialized
ramps and housing developed so their
child can exist
you can tell your kid to not be an
[ __ ] if these other families can have
children who've been injured in disease
and illness and accidents and then learn
how to raise them
through that you can tell tommy not to
be a dick yeah no it's true like my
friend was talking about asperger's i'm
like that's an excuse i don't [ __ ] with
asperger's
because it's just i want to be a dick
that's what asperger's is to me
everybody i've ever i have asperger's
like you were just a [ __ ] rude piece
of [ __ ]
well me oh i'm i'm i'm just a thief i'm
going to steal all your [ __ ] then
because
if we can have excuses i have asperger's
that's why i called you a [ __ ]
no it's not why you called well then
there needs to be a conversation about
it then
society needs to be responsible and be
like well this is something that could
happen this is like
something for people to be aware of if
that's a scenario like set me up so i
know that somebody can be an [ __ ] and
have asperger's
thank you let me know thank you like no
i have asperger's too i'm just a piece
of [ __ ]
that if they [ __ ] owned up mike you
know what let's hang out
because that's that's somebody you need
when you go out drinking like no
because people watch please yo i love i
hate going to bars
but i love people watching sometimes
it's the greatest the best
watch like watch this guy get turned
down right now oh he got turned down
right now
and trying to figure out who's on first
dates and stuff that's easy
have you ever heard of the new york
state fair on movies
yeah it's a tri-state fair in my
hometown where i grew up
and it is it is the olympics of people
watching
you will see people of all walks of life
mainly people walking down meth lane
but also all walks of life i think
a lot of meth yeah it's like this huge
part of the carnival oh
i know can you believe it oh they get in
they run the rides
oh for sure yeah yeah yeah carnies are
meth heads
pedophiles traveling pedophiles is what
that the guy who runs the ring of fire
not necessarily a stable individual
yeah no meth heads we have one fair
besides
but it's the best for for people
watching it's so amazing so
syracuse yeah it's called the new york
state fair obviously didn't happen last
year because of the pandemic but if
anyone can get to it
it's worth traveling to syracuse for
what's
sarah i mean i am so [ __ ] geography
geographically however the [ __ ] she's
graphically challenged
see i can't even speak same so syracuse
new york i
how where is that to new york city
because i know home alone
chinese meetings with turtles that's
like i said that's all my new york
knowledge that's a good that's actually
a good that's it point of reference
that's a good starting i can find
the hotel it's about pretty much it
four and a half hours northwest
of see syracuse is right there and you
see down to the bottom right
that's new york city so it's a pretty
diagonal across
um down through pennsylvania you're
right on the border of canada yeah we're
right on the border canada so we kind of
sound
you can hear my accent everyone kind of
sounds like this and it's like a
flat minnesota but also it's like it's
minnesota right
oh i just know bobby bobby uh bobby's
world
the mom yeah that's the only time i
remember that bobby don't you know bobby
dude i met howie mandel and i lost my
mind i was doing just for laughs
the year before last and i was doing the
nasty show it was
me andrew schultz big jay okerson bonnie
mcfarlane
um cp who else was on the show
jim jeffrey stopped by and jimmy carr
was like a huge comedian
in in lunch yeah english guys so [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you would love him no he's funny he is
so funny he's funny as [ __ ]
and i did my set and afterwards
howie mandel came up to me because i
went over to the roast battle you know
jeff ross's roast battle
he's a friend of mine and i wanted to go
over there and check it out howie mandel
comes
up to me and like fangirls me
he goes oh my god you were like you're
fantastic
you're like he called me and i don't
humble brag much but i've been through a
lot i've been very humbled i've been
raped my dad died and my mom just died
in november so i can say this [ __ ] you
um he called me the future of comedy and
i was like
nice explosion i just
i grew up watching him like you know
bobby's world and walk like a man do you
remember that movie where he was raised
by
wolves okay why did i just [ __ ] hear
about this
did you not know about this movie no i
just always assume
you're so close to jeff goldblum in the
fly i'm just gonna say it's the same
[ __ ] to me because
i was a child i did not watch that movie
it's so 80s it's so quintessential 80s
which is the third time i've said
quintessential today
i love those movies man so great the 80s
movies were so
iconic and all his stand up i was look
at look
at so this woman i expected him to be
part dog he was raised by dogs he
literally was raised like in the woods
and this woman takes him in because
again women were like oh my god i can't
find any man let me get like the half
wolf man
because he'll love me so she raises him
and turns him into like a distinguished
you know civilized human being
[Music]
by the way that's what my [ __ ] looked
like after quarantine like i just got
rid of all that that was my ball
there was a carrot in it yeah yeah cause
it's been lonely
he looks like the guy from the dungeon
in aladdin that [ __ ]
dupes his ass he does that's what he
looks like that guy
oh my god this is 1987 what year were
you born
89. okay cool so he honestly was just
the man of the 80s and to have him like
recognize me as a peer or somebody he
enjoyed
that oh yeah oh it's such a great movie
you've got you've got to get stoned and
watch this movie of course
oh my god of course leachman i'm with it
this one's [ __ ] on the table i'm
gonna watch this
friday that's a friday i'm gonna watch
this i do this thing i've started to do
this thing on youtube
and facebook before they [ __ ] you yes
and
it's called bam it's bong and movie and
i get stoned and i go live
and i watch him and everyone can watch
the movie with me because we couldn't go
to movie theaters and
literally i know you said that it is my
favorite thing
to do to go to movies like what about it
for you do you love so much
um i love getting what i do is i smoke a
[ __ ] little weed at home i get to the
theater i smoke a shillow weed in the
car
until it's four minutes before yeah and
i like the we're gonna [ __ ] make it
because you know when you're so [ __ ]
up you kind of forget like i locked the
car i know i locked the car i know i
locked the car and i get in there and go
oh [ __ ] i forgot to get a drink
and i rush in there and then i look god
nobody's sitting next to me
and then i sit there and as soon as all
those things are checked i go [ __ ] yeah
and i sit there and forget the [ __ ] what
i watched every time oh that sounds so
it's maybe the weed
the weed that you love so much and you
can be doing anything that's what i was
that's what i heard
you're like i smoke so much in the
parking lot and i smoke weed in the car
and then i forget if i locked my car
i guess so yeah yeah i mean you don't
need an excuse to like to smoke weed
i just want i just like to go to because
i've seen i i have a photographic memory
like to the max so i watch a movie i
know the whole movie
so watching a new movie it's like [ __ ]
yeah i have no idea what's happening
sick
because you know what i mean yeah cause
let's just get bored that's interesting
you have a photographic memory is that
something you always had as a kid yeah
did you do well in school
super minimal effort exactly i was on
the gifted classes and all that [ __ ] and
then i started smoking weed and went
well [ __ ] the get to classes no you're
like this is this is a gift this is
yep but i'm really good with all that i
just never utilized it i went to college
i talked about where did you go to
college oh gosh
i went to merced university of phoenix
online college
for five years i went to community
college for a year and a half don't
knock it that shit's
cheap over five years oh [ __ ] that's a
long time i didn't graduate
that's fine you spoke a week were you
dealing yeah oh yeah that was a whole
year
you weren't at college you were running
a business yes i was running a [ __ ]
business okay let's
get it right what did you study do you
remember
business and then my okay walked into my
first class first day of college and i'm
like you know what stick with it
you're gonna get it do good and my
teacher i swear to [ __ ] god i hope
somebody watching was there in that
class
he goes hey the teacher 43 years i have
seven months of sick days and this is
the year i take him
that's what he said he goes i will not
show up monday through thursday fridays
make sure you be here and go get the
[ __ ] out here
love you so so he just said he's gonna
pass everybody no i failed
no yeah i failed the class
that's great because i was like you know
what he's not going to show up this
friday
and then he dropped me because i missed
so many days i mean i get that because
he gave you such a layup and you're like
meh
[ __ ] it but i also respect it i respect
that you're like why
why friday why not just i went for
months too that's [ __ ] great
it's so stupid and i saw his stupid ass
at the store
when his class was going on and i wasn't
that clown like yo you're not in class
either
[ __ ] it he straight up said this is the
year i take i'm like wow
what did you sell them a bag in the
parking lot no i never sold any teachers
weed
what no they need it the most my i was
always uh
i'm always very cautious of who i sold
weed to because i don't want them to go
hey
thomas tells me no i don't well he's a
teacher we believe him kick my door and
find all these pounds
yeah [ __ ] no nobody five years of school
i would go for four months and then go
you know what next time
and then i'd quit or i drop and then i'd
wait for the next semester
[ __ ] i [ __ ] up a lot in school
i think people i'm similar to you i did
as well like i
just [ __ ] off and i did what i needed
to do to pass and i got
really great grades without trying
trying i went to gifted two
i went to a gifted school oh the whole
school yeah i got picked up at my
regular school
i'm pretty sure was like not a gifted
school and i just was really dumb but
i'm going with that narrative
i'm going that narrative they taught me
greek mythology and english lit so i'm
going i was like you were definitely not
in the dump kids school at all it was
wild [ __ ] i hated you see all your
friends you talk to your friends after
class like what's your homework well
[ __ ] all you and then you have a book to
read oh you have to read iliad and
you're like seven
i [ __ ] hated school so much because
you get your ass whooped if you don't go
yeah and it's also it's so standardized
it doesn't work
like people like you and i where we're
we're creative and i feel like our
specific brain just doesn't work for
that
type of teaching we get we're the ones
who get failed by the school
we're not failing because we're not
smart smart we're just it's not built
for us
it's true it's difficult and now like i
was saying the other day because i have
little brothers and sisters that are
15 and down so they
imagined imagine school and then going
what's the best part about school chill
my friends
well now you got none of them let's sit
at home that [ __ ] sucks
i can't imagine the cannabis here it
must have been so so hard
and also for those developmental
children oh it's over
socializing that's one of the most
important factors of a human
well just they reverted five absolutely
i used to work in the uh pow it's called
pals it's uh
the handicap mentally handicapped kid
class so i had it for like six seven
years
you worked there but in school it's like
instead of doing an elective
yeah yeah and you have to be social
they they if not i've seen those kids
like bite you back
not even my mom used to get bit all the
time there was one kid that used to bite
people but they knew better
yeah they knew better maybe it was a
syracuse thing they were hungry there
my mom used to have them over all the
time mentally challenged kids
they were hungry there they were very
hungry there was this little kid timmy
used to come over my mom would watch him
and you dry hump me every time and my
mom would just smoke a cigarette it's
fine
let him let him do what he wanted he's
special
[Laughter]
don't be afraid he's dry help my legs my
mom
smoke a cigarette like you wouldn't try
on me like mom
this kid won't stop was he younger at
least he was the same age but i think
that's a similar it's a
common factor in mentally challenged
some actively challenged people
seeing that in my life they get sexual
they're more sexually active because
they don't have that filter
which sounds great sounds great
we just solved rapist like yo he's
[ __ ] stupid
he's just stupid oh
whoa that [ __ ] just came full [ __ ]
circle right now
but no that's definitely not it no no
that's not it but no the kid i've never
had any kids do that
maybe it was just maybe they were hungry
in syracuse totally different
my mom used to have to wrap her forearms
so she wouldn't get bit
oh that's a whole different type of
mentally challenged okay that's like the
sporadic
it's like zombies simon mentally
challenged just like zombies
where's that movie zombies oh i'm just
going to be jumping like bruce lee and
crushing all these zombies how much fun
sounds so sad oh that was kind of
terrible i'm like i love mentally
challenged children let's kill
zombie babies could you a man what actor
hold on what actor is going to get that
role of of the
hero of the zombie baby
david arquette boom
i saw david get drunk and high and i saw
him freestyle rap one time
and i was recording him and then at the
end i go i'm hot i didn't press record
five minutes straight he freestyled and
it was not good
was he in it like did he really think it
was good oh he had his hat crooked he
thought he was the [ __ ] it was at a
weed event and he stood on the table
and i go yo is that [ __ ] scary
movie or from us
from scream yeah and that courtney cox's
boyfriend
and then he was with my friend and go
why do you know david arquette
and then he stood up on a table with a
[ __ ] sponsored hat turned it to the
side and started
doing this nope i swear i'm a [ __ ]
life somebody's got it oh someone's got
it on twitter oh my gosh
i stood there like this like no there's
no way i'm not getting it
and then i look down and gets [ __ ]
zeros at the top i never press
there's no way i'm not getting it i'm
totally filming this whole thing
i felt so bad i'm not bad i felt so
played like yo i had gold
i had i had gold and i didn't get any
you have a photographic memory
i know exactly what it looks like what
was he wearing he was wearing jeans
like a beige looking shirt and he had a
[ __ ] sponsored
uh uh dr green no doctor zodiac hat
how did his jeans fit were they loose
boot cut
he's probably stepping on the back of
his shoes is this the night
he looks like a lot of fun he honestly
he looks like the most
fun everybody was ready to rumble
anybody that was in ready to rumble
i'm [ __ ] down with yeah he was kind
of a cute fella
too like he could have caught it in the
him yeah he 90s have caught it for sure
the way you said that was great
he could have caught it he's like the
better jason biggs yeah
yeah yeah jason is great but he's
funnier if i get high and drunk enough
and i look at david arquette maybe he
could look like brad pitt but like
through
put through like stretch through like a
fun house it's like thomas you're
six one like definitely six months
that's the same [ __ ] thing
oh my god is that him now oh no
yeah there's a lot going on now life is
hard you know look at that one
yeah yeah oh yeah he looks real fun he
looks like a funny he's lived a life
though you know it's like
you being one of the friends yeah that's
pretty cool
you can put that on his tombstone like i
was banging monica
and she was like she was a it girl for a
hundred for a minute yeah
until did you ever see 3 000 miles to
graceland
no what is that it's a movie with kevin
costner and god i love kevin costner
he's awesome he's such a bad actor but i
love him so much
he's not good ready okay okay i'm mad
my wife's dead the wolves indians the
same [ __ ] face
it's the same [ __ ] face it's bad yes
it's the same face
wait a minute he's great though wait a
minute bodyguard
he definitely has a [ __ ] face
only keanu reeves can do the no acting
actor thing
you know what i mean calories just woke
up and go
john wick
another one i would definitely let keanu
catch it my heart
let him catch my heart my heart i'm
gonna bring my heart first i'm gonna
bring one thing up real quick
because i saw something and i went oh we
have the same
[ __ ] love for this man i love the
[ __ ] out of john stamos
oh my god see that's my origin that's my
og
to the max the emotion is my og first
hair i'm like yo can i get my hair like
that yeah his hair is everything in his
smile he's the
[ __ ] oh my god look at his young
adult picture
blown up framed in my house no you don't
oil volley sent it to me when i did the
campaign
yep and i there's a it's just it's above
my bed it's court material
it's squirt material it's a squirt board
i aim and i squirt on it
i put a bullseye on his mouth
[Laughter]
oh yeah he's messaged me very he's very
friendly like not like
inappropriately he's a very nice guy he
actually when my father passed away sent
me a video and a message
really yeah [ __ ] john stamos yeah i
still squirt on him though
oh my god remember that thing you said
for my dad yeah lay down
lay down because mama's got some a
little bit of kitten juice she wants you
to
save her yo that first one looks like he
would rob you
oh yeah the first one looks like he
would rob you in a broadway musical
not in real life just spin and take your
[ __ ] he'll do a jump split and then take
your purse yo he looks so much like my
[ __ ] daddy adrian
what yo that's [ __ ] crazy your dad
looked like john stevens
i'm saying like that first picture looks
like my [ __ ] dad and they oh my god
he looks like my dad
where's your dad now cause i want to
talk to him he's driving a truck
somewhere damn the hanging earrings yeah
boys yeah that should have been lost
boys not to fake jim morrison yes
that's a really good call right yes
that's what [ __ ] murdered it
i just love that he can be so much older
now and still be so damn
and he doesn't take himself too
seriously like he understands his iconic
he's younger just impression
he loves it yeah and i think it's so
funny look at him looking like a woman
in the top right daily my mom in the 80s
look at that mullet
look at that full [ __ ] mullet are you
kidding me
i love the fact that we are both on how
what when did your love
start for him full house yeah he was the
coolest guy ever uncle jeff see the song
go yo what's up with that hair can i get
that hair
that's all i remember that my mom go my
mom would always
john's team i was going why are you
always looking at john stamos like that
mom like oil is on my dad
oh oh look at that picture
oh my god that [ __ ] looks like
prince i need that tank top
look at his looking picture he looks
like the drawings
that corolla de ville does in the 101
dalmatians he looks like a woman who
does
hair in wichita that's a great way to
put it
amid somebody from terms of endearment
and i mean that
with all my heart and love in a good way
yeah in a really great way
he's the [ __ ] coolest does is he
still acting does he still do like he's
he has a show that just came out on at
disney plus i think
i [ __ ] love that yeah and he's got a
beautiful wife i don't it probably won't
last but i'm sure they're happy
they probably won't last wait wasn't he
married to that that supermodel chick
yeah rebecca romain and then she married
jerry o'connell
and then he turned into a blow up down
that kid from he reverted back to st
have we seen him lately oh i can't i
mean his wife
john stamos's wife is he looks like
those uh pocahontas we all hoped for he
looks like those uh those little dogs
with the mustaches she's just so
beautiful
are you kidding his wife is just so
gorgeous she looks like she's gonna be
an x-men
she doesn't need a stitch of makeup and
this beard oh man i bet you that thing
smells like procreation and what's your
procreation
are you kidding me oh god that sounds
like smells
juice earth and girth
that's the name of my album
yeah they've got a little boy he's
adorable oh he's gonna love his life
oh of course you know my [ __ ] dad is
i know who my [ __ ]
dad is that is so insane the
older he's getting the more he looks
like my [ __ ] family that's that's
crazy that is insane
it's also unfair in society the older
man gets the more distinguished she
becomes and when a woman gets older we
become a witch
this is what society uh oh uh oh we're
googling
you like my dad yeah can we find your
dad is he googlable didn't you just post
them
uh he's probably on my instagram you
posted okay we need to find your dad
yeah he drives a truck he's a truck
driver oh that's kind of hot
so when he was young when he was real
young that's exactly what the [ __ ] that
fool looked like how crazy
and oh that's my dad now well not now
but like a couple years ago
okay is he in a purple
business suit i know he's a he's what
you call a father now
so he has a vest on does he have like a
more kids after you isn't that great
when they do that
growing up he was all [ __ ] up he was
all like twacked so did he get a chance
to redeem himself
i never give a [ __ ] no we always say
that
i truly don't though really yeah like
somewhere inside
who cares no i'm just glad that like my
little brothers and sisters
like he's a dad yeah he shows up to
games he's not on drugs
was he on drugs when you were growing up
yeah that must have been [ __ ]
terrible
no i didn't know until i was like you
know how i've realized that
when i was sneaking my joints with my
friends like yo let's go to the fields
and i'm like why is my dad and i give a
[ __ ] that we're out oh you're snorting
meth in the garage
that's why we're like nah he has no idea
what we're doing and meanwhile he's in
there going they got no [ __ ] idea
what i'm doing so you guys are doing the
same thing
but an opposite end of the spectrum yep
that was my dad
that's kind of beautiful he's awesome my
dad's very [ __ ] he's the most
offensive person
ever and you've talked to me and even
still
worse because he doesn't think it's
offensive and he says it to be humans
like
normal human beings the [ __ ] he says
i've talked about it before the [ __ ] he
says is so [ __ ]
but that's like my dad was the same way
that they're from a different era and
people will say
something about us he knows in that
sense he knows he's what he's doing
of course we used to go on moves with
him because the movie company
the [ __ ] i have to apologize for him so
much like when he leaves her i'm so
sorry
because people going through divorce my
dad obviously they're not [ __ ]
together dad
where's your husband ally we're picking
stuff out of each room [ __ ] we
are setting
suits on fire john
is not coming back i've left holmen's
closet wardrobes and go oh they're
getting divorced
we have to be out here by 12 30. oh he
doesn't know yet
and like i said one time the guy showed
up magic [ __ ]
you need to write a tv show about the
moving company
and your life the movie coming we've
seen some [ __ ] i'm telling you
that is [ __ ] funny it's funny it's
really unique and it's so unique to you
i would love to watch that [ __ ] it's
like uh watching cheers but every time
there's a new cast
i swear if you're coming to the same
people we get in the truck
it could be a show i'm i like that
listen
i like that i have to sell wheat on the
side on delivery yes that make it a
little better you got to put the weed in
it because it's natural to you
for sure it's just so weird on my pizza
car because i used to deliver pizza
i mean weed and pizza i would people are
ordering that together now
yeah of course yeah of course are you
kidding me yeah
it's a blunt and a pie have you ever
seen a pizza guy get pulled over
no thank you that's why i did it
because i would cover pounds in my car
oh and when i was not at work i'd leave
the sign on and just go drop pounds off
okay we're changing the tv show to that
we have two tv shows to write there's
some marty get on it we have two tv
shows to write i want executive producer
credit
i want co-creative you're the first drug
you're the first customer in the show
i'm i want to be a crackhead so bad oh
[ __ ]
there's a sound bite foreign i think i
can pull it up
i just don't want to smoke crack i just
want all the ambitions of a crack i've
said this before yes
they have the best life you just fall
asleep
wherever you sleep literally deep sleep
no bills did you see that new movie wait
selena
uh um what's her name she's so
one of the most beautiful women in the
world actress and owen wilson
why can't i think why the [ __ ] did we
just watch that movie last night
selma hayek how [ __ ] that damn movie
last night
isn't it what an ending wasn't it like
what the are they on drugs
or are they for real such a good ending
i think that all the time like all these
crackheads down here i'm like
what if they're just having the best
[ __ ] time and their body's just here
but they're somewhere else right
the realms are completely bled through
that sounds because i've done meth four
that's not the way it works you're not a
genius doctor who lives in like i don't
think like yo i'm going to [ __ ]
paradise i'm just like no
what can i sell that's there's no
that was a hollywood method it was a
hollywood trip
but it was very she put little rocks in
that thing like yo
that's supposed to be meth they're crack
rocks there's mess i mean for what i saw
yeah but i'm like i uh meth looks like
ice
like ice cubes right like little like
shards so when i saw them like
are they [ __ ] drug addicts and i saw
and i'm like oh my god she's got a
boondoggle kit
oh my god i thought i'm like oh my god
she went to michael's yo she looked
so natural as a crackhead she it really
[ __ ] me i'm like no
she did so my could pull off being a
crasher she could pull she could pull
anything off truly she's so good yo
one of the sexiest scenes in cinema
i don't know what you're going to say
from dusto dog i already knew the
nastiest part also when she was like
yo you're trying to drink this foot wine
that [ __ ] made me [ __ ] dry here
this is what i'm telling you squirting
it's not too far from footwork when she
poured the wine
like yo because that was like fine i
don't think quentin sucks on toast
quitting that [ __ ] loved that
scene he sure did he
only wrote that [ __ ] yeah he only wrote
that [ __ ] he was like hold up take the
director's chair i got him
on this toe just make her feet come out
yo we don't have a scene yet i don't
care
somebody write a scene around her foot
in my mouth however we have to do it
he backtracks like he [ __ ] does his
movies like no we start with feet
back check what happens we don't we
don't know
how does he write his movies
i love all of his movies they're good
so much very good i i one of my favorite
ones was that hateful eight even though
it was mad long it was long but such a
great cast
so good i love movies that can stay
right here in dialogue and never leave
like a play like uh in glorious bastards
right three hours of [ __ ] three and a
half hours of talking
and i was interested the whole [ __ ]
time and hateful eight was in one
location
one i mean besides like their building
it was one
one room and it really showed like
acting as an art with a dynamic between
all the different actors
would you forget someone as an actor you
go who are they oh my god i forgot
that's what's his face
i know it sounds real dumb because i
always go
you know it's one of the best acting
jobs of all time only because you forget
that it's
joe dirt david spade you forget it's
david speaker
i love this guy oh yeah that's david
spade
i look like that in the morning by the
way like
i was sitting did you see how i was
sitting waiting for you to tell me i was
like you're like you know one of my
favorite movies i was like i don't
children
i wake up looking like joe dirt he's the
coolest dude i understand why he pulls
hot women does he he's he's the coolest
dude dave's paint pulls
he's [ __ ] yeah he's so funny and so
intelligent
like his comedy i've always loved him
he's another icon the dude's been around
forever
yes but he still looks amazing i mean
he's a little fella no offense i'm sure
he probably hates that but
i like a big ass i'm sure jason i like a
big ass
earth and girth is what i'm going for
the jason among man that's a [ __ ]
specimen of a person
that full looks like a brick he should
sell his semen on amazon
yo stop would you buy some nope
i'm thirsty no but could you imagine
yeah people would pay millions of
dollars but like no no brad pitts brad
pitt what i mean
if you ever gave me the pinch yes i can
i just thought it
would really really pay for that like
thousands
maybe even millions of dollars just so
they can go [ __ ] my purse i have brad
pitt's kid
yes could you imagine it's a business
johnny depp in five years like well the
acting's not going good
johnny depp must be a lot to be married
to i wonder if he has so many
accessories
so many it must take him forever to like
go to bed at night before wakes no he
in fourth grade used to put my clothes
on and wake up and go straight to school
because i don't want to get ready in the
morning i would do that too
yeah i should do that oh she was on too
[ __ ] that
i would do it i would do it never did
the backpack
i never did the backpack but i also
never did my homework
that's funny i used to do that too it's
the best i would wake up ten minutes you
look next to the school
oh it's five minutes so class starts
[ __ ] yeah and put my [ __ ] on i just do
high school
bomb though wasn't it i hated it you did
see i loved it i just loved maybe it's
because we're coming out of quarantine
just like the community and being around
children were they [ __ ] to you
i don't speak spanish in a mexican town
oh damn
yeah wow that's weird because i only
spoke spanish
[Laughter]
lo siento ideo samio yono lo crayo
i'm gonna i'm gonna learn something that
nobody i'm gonna learn german
someone around my family i'm gonna well
do you [ __ ] know german
is there a more jarring sounding
language than germany
saying you look very nice today sounds
like some hits
is that really what i don't know i don't
know you probably said something really
bad in german
i probably said something so bad some
german people are going to write how it
was a hate crime well you guys did the
largest hate crime in america
ever in history
remember that one time at german camp
remember that time at summer camp where
you [ __ ]
or nobody passed remember that one time
at concentration camp
oh man oh man
half my family's going ah and the other
half is [ __ ] mexican
we all need to laugh more it's funny i
mean making fun of [ __ ] that makes
people uncomfortable is
the goal it breaks it breaks through to
the healing it
truly does because if you get triggered
you know where your
place from work is you know where you
need to start your work i like that
anytime you watch something and it makes
you mad
that is your source of everything that's
your source of self
your ego's been hiding it because you're
afraid of healing but your source of
self is letting you know oh that hurt
we got to pay more attention to that hmm
yeah it's all about the self and the ego
and the battle between the two
that's what i think i always think of it
as like um we're all the same but skin
color
and and ethnic backgrounds why not make
fun of it
yeah i agree why can't i make fun of my
mexican ass family with gold
[ __ ] plants or the fact you went you
were in a mexican town you didn't speak
spanish
please for the love
of dios
write a [ __ ] show because your story
is so
interesting it'd be fun it'd be a fun
it'd be a
fun one i always imagined it as a
remember the beginning of breaking bad
where walt finds jesse sneaking out of
that lady's apartment yes through the
window
yeah just start off from there and you
never met wall and then like we'll just
do that show
cause could you imagine his life like
you're banging this lady you jumped out
of a window you're selling pounds of
wheat
you got a nice [ __ ] car this is
a good job yeah where's he gonna go
where's he gonna go oh white man messed
him up
that was such a sad show it was so it
was so cool i love that
it completed it was perfect you know i
love that it had
some sort of completion to it and it was
sad
but it was such a great depiction of
what people are capable of in times of
desperation
of course also we need health care
that part in healthcare that doesn't
cost a thousand dollars a month
not even that like he was dying he's a
[ __ ]
teacher no you're gonna die you got
money [ __ ]
i'm a government worker doesn't matter
doesn't matter that's scary he just went
to canada
but that whole show he should just went
to ottawa the whole show stops
if he had health care right the whole
show stops also if he goes to niagara
falls
and then crosses the border i have so
many people hit me up from canada like
you don't have health care like are you
[ __ ] you have no education system
then because you don't know we don't
have health care [ __ ] we have
health don't care that's what we have
in this country that's how it feels i
paid so much money they did go to the
doctor and thought
my healthcare is like seven hundred
dollars a month i don't wanna get it
i know and it's like
just the fact that there are things in
in nature
that can provide true healing that the
government feels a desire to
separate us from is that there's too
much money in pharmaceuticals
way too much money and i don't even talk
about that [ __ ] too crazy because i
don't want the government kick my damn
door in
but i'll talk about it there's way too
much money in pharmaceuticals it's very
true
we have rockefeller and carnegie to
blame for that [ __ ] it's um
it but then again it's it's a it's crack
head [ __ ] it's like cracked you like yo
sell crack this lady every day or send
her to the give her a pamphlet for the
rehab next door like
well she's waiting for me giving her
crack anyways yeah but they
he don't make no money anymore right i'm
saying like that's pharmaceuticals they
don't want to solve your cancer
problem they're like oh we have the cure
but it's kind of cheap
what about this [ __ ] every month yep i
understand
the business i get why they do it
there's pieces of [ __ ]
it is it's it's just unfortunate never
had nobody [ __ ] in their family get
sick then
yeah they don't understand like how hard
it is for people and how like when my
dad was sick
you know one of the most expensive
diseases to have is something where
somebody has
a an irreversible neurodegenerative
disease like alzheimer's or parkinson's
like lou gehrig's
that sort of thing where the end is
imminent and and how it's going to go is
imminent
and the cost is so high because
it's such a hard thing to diagnose and
it has so many stages
my father had what we think vascular
dementia
and never heard of that it's it's
usually brought on by a stroke like it
can be brought on abruptly
and we just thought
and society has just thought it's you
know old-timers that's the that's what
alzheimer's has always been called
old-timers that that's just a part of
getting old and it's not
that's true it's a huge misconception
the the
alzheimer's and dementia are not a
normal part of the aging process but
it's such an expensive disease to have
because by the time
you have somewhat of an idea of what's
going on you're already
thousands of dollars in the hole from
home care because it's the sort of thing
that how it evolves
you're just plugging holes in the ship
yeah you're like oh he doesn't know how
to get to his doctor today
okay that's fine we'll just get him some
ginkgo biloba
and then oh he didn't know what day it
was that's fine we'll just
we'll just remind him and you keep
providing
solutions to a problem you don't
understand and then
it turns into a thing where it's like oh
he's peeing in the plant in the corner
well maybe we need someone to come over
to the house and take care of him
instead of fix
it right because we we don't it's still
that sort of thing is still stigmatized
and it's
like just what happens yeah and it's the
number five
cause of death in america
why oh because the brain deteriorates
well yeah but it the brain deteriorates
and
you know there's so many causes they
think that like a lifestyle
environmental
diet there's a small portion of it that
is
genetic or familial that causes it but
it's a huge killer and it's something
that is so expensive and when it comes
to health care
we paid out of pocket my sister paid 30
40 grand out of pocket for my dad's home
care before we even got him into the
system before we were even able
to deal with it because it's not the
type of disease where
you can scan and it shows up on a chart
it's it's
50 things and go this is probably it's
probably a year this is what it is
exactly it just bread crumbs itself into
your life and by the time the whole loaf
is gone
you're broke and you have to find a way
to
hopefully get them someplace where they
can be cared for
it's a brutal thing you know and like
people you know i i feel like
i don't know there's just it's just it's
brutal it's just hard you know it's hard
for people that have to go through
something like that and lose all that
money
you know luckily my sister and her
family and myself
you know we were able to like navigate
through it but a lot of people can't
yeah and they and they become broke and
they go out on and then they get
misplaced and they they lose their homes
and they're out in the street like
it is a vicious [ __ ] cycle fast it's
so fast and that's why i can understand
you know sucking a dick for a dollar
[ __ ] i just was trying to lighten it up
and i didn't know what to do i forgot
that i didn't like sucking dick is i
have dementia so i suck a dick for a
dollar
for free i forgot i was trying to get
the money
yo stop i forgot to get the money
oh my god hey what's up everybody
dopaziola here thank you so much for
tuning in to another episode of the dope
as usual podcast
as always guys i want to say shout out
to stereo our ad our first sponsor ever
first people to ever [ __ ] with us thank
you so much stereo app if you haven't
been on there marty and i have been
doing
lives where me and marty just talk [ __ ]
for an hour three times a week i'm not
sure what days we haven't really settled
on them but we do it three times a week
guys i post on my instagram my snapchat
stereo app click the link below download
the app follow us
dope as usual on stereo like i said it's
live
it's live chat it's for us you can
actually send voice messages we can
answer your question
everybody hears your question it's
[ __ ] cool so go check it out stereo
app click the link below
download it dope as usual like i said it
really helps out
it's in every link every video it's in
the description
thank you guys so much shout out to
stereo
[ __ ] yeah that one time i did the
[ __ ] ad read write
holy [ __ ] right i don't even have one
this time
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay here we go
i had this character and it was so
[ __ ] offensive i wrote a bunch of
characters out because i just thought
you know that's pretty [ __ ] funny but
nobody's gonna think it's funny except
for me but you might
so i'll just say it now i had a bunch of
characters and i wrote one out
since we were talking about the topic
earlier
i'm scared i'm scared for all of us it's
i don't know how we got on both of these
[ __ ] topics and that's exactly my
character
my character was the dementia riddled
rapist
he can't remember that rape is bad shut
up
and he also says did you rape this woman
i've never seen her before
shut up that was the characters it will
never stop sorry it'll never
stop you're lying i swear i've written
down like the dementia riddle rapist
like why
you can't remember that it's wrong and
that was it
where where is this written i need my
name pat paris
i have a no i have a green notebook like
water boy where i write my [ __ ]
um i tried it out on my mom and she
laughed but she's also offensive as [ __ ]
so it's just things like that that i
can't talk about all the time
yeah but it's funny that she you're fine
with it because most people are fine
with it because i don't
and i'm going to say a statement that is
coming from heart and love i don't
believe there is
i don't believe that there is um
offensiveness i believe there's unhealed
trauma
and i think that it's a very black and
white thing i think that people who
like i've said before if they become
triggered by a subject
it's because that subject is deep within
their soul
and they haven't healed from it and we
don't really have a society that
makes healing easy for everybody especi
especially from a socio-economic
standpoint
just make fun of you yeah that's what
the world is
you have problems right exactly you're a
[ __ ] that's all you're gonna hear like
go to therapy and that's it
that's all you're gonna hear because
people will always be like well i should
have said more when somebody kills
himself and like well he reached out to
you 10 times [ __ ] and told you like
hey some shit's going on
right like reaching out looks different
you have to sort of have your
not a text right it's it's that's tough
you know
everyone's so much in their own caught
up in their own world and
when people reach out and are going
through hard times man that's
and we all can go through it i think
like you know i'm sure you've
maybe experienced it too where you just
have dark thoughts but
certain people can't get out of those
dark thoughts you know and that's like
what makes what you and i do so
important because i feel i really truly
feel like
what i do provides people a reprieve
from whatever their
deal is of course you know it's a break
outlet yes
it takes if you could take your like say
your back hurts and you watch something
hilarious and it stops you go [ __ ] yeah
my back is killing me from all that
dick last night sorry guys i'm sorry i
know it's one tone today
it's okay but do you see what i'm saying
it's something takes your brain off it's
it's music it's it's movies it's the
same [ __ ]
it really is the same and if you're
laughing you can't be
[ __ ] violently mad and start laughing
because you're like i'm not
mad then you just start being you just
start laughing so people are depressed
and sad
as soon as they start laughing they
forget that they're sad it's a beautiful
thing it's awesome
it really is i see the comments all the
time people it
it you're a beam of light for sure like
i you and i have never physically met
but i know marty and uh he turned me on
to you and you're just
you you emit energy and bright energy
and fun
and you can tell you love what you do
yeah and and you can tell what you do
you feel is important because
you understand that you understand the
power of it yeah there's a lot of noise
so i'm glad someone like you is
that need it especially the quarantine
yes we're pumping out as much as we
could just
people need that [ __ ] they do and
especially like a mexican man to succeed
and do his own damn thing
yeah you don't see it often well not
brown kids at least yeah i feel like
they need representation they need to
see someone like you like
breaking stigmas and going against the
grain and like
creating something for yourself and
being successful from your own
being not working under the guise of
some other huge company yeah you are the
company
that's the whole that's pretty dope yeah
that's the whole point that's dope as
yola
yeah we uh like i said it wasn't started
like that it's just all dru i was just
selling drugs and then i got a
smartphone
and then that's what happened well there
goes my whole story there goes my whole
complimentary like no it's not that deep
i just was selling dough
now it got that way to where it's like
i never tried to do it you know yeah it
never came like that you were meant to
yeah it just started like we just
started talking camera two years ago
before that i'm like i'm fine i don't
wanna talk on camera it's just scary as
[ __ ]
and then once you do it it's so much
once the first person comes i'm like
you made my [ __ ] day like yes okay
now i feel
better even if i [ __ ] up there's people
out there like i'm
i'm so bummed right now and the [ __ ]
made me laugh and that's
the best part it is it's the [ __ ]
coolest part you know i feel like you
need to talk to is
joey diaz i feel like you two people
call me the young joey diaz a lot
um except the only difference is like i
don't pull my dick out
i didn't sell coke that's unfortunate oh
i'm old for two that was him that was
him
he's a wild mother he pulled his nuts
out on the uh comedy store
fundraising live for the employees
yeah for the employees of the comedy
store for the staff to raise money for
them during
quarantine he pulled his nuts out it was
the greatest thing
i've never seen that joey diaz i can't
stop thinking about it he is just so
lovable
and he's the coolest he lives from his
heart you know what i mean he
talks from his heart he's not
sugarcoating [ __ ] he's not sugarcoating
[ __ ] it's the best thing
you know maybe some of his stuff is uh
the more vulgar the more friends of the
people right
and is that better he's a real person
he's a real person he's the guy to sell
we too
he's just he's lived a life he's been
humbled
he has been so humbled in so many
different areas but he's
like a handful of people who stayed in
touch with me during quarantine and like
checked in at me like josh wolfe who i
know you know is that [ __ ] so
cool
last time in mushrooms with josh here
really
yeah because every the first time i ever
met the man he ate a handful of
mushrooms dry
just chomped him down just dry like yes
no water no
water he's magical he's amazing so when
he came here
i got mushroom caps and we took them
they didn't hit us till his high life
started but it was fun
i love that [ __ ] dude he's one of the
greatest
he really is like that's my brother him
diaz
like i have a handful of like really
good people who
stayed in touch and made he text me josh
is like you good what's going on like
they they just
there's people like that who are special
they actually care
they actually care yeah you know just
tag you on instagram and [ __ ]
right [ __ ] hit you up yeah there's a
there's i have a few people in my life
like that so yeah
it's different it's different and i have
a friend who well
someone i know who when my dad died
tweeted about it
didn't didn't even so much as text me
or call me he [ __ ] tweeted a photo
that he took of my father and i from
years ago and i was like
bro no
gross gross confirm or deny in the
comments below
gross gross ugh just so
like
[Laughter]
no um yeah bruno
yeah that's rude horrible hardcore rude
whoa i don't think i ever heard
something like that right
i [ __ ] up i'm not even in shows i
never heard that before
i mean was at least your close friend
nah not anymore
i was like bye yeah i love when people
do that though
this isn't great i [ __ ] love when
people [ __ ] up and go
see ya
i don't have to worry about your
bitch-ass during christmas none of your
birthdays they don't matter anymore [ __ ]
yes
it is it sounds so bad no it's not it's
friendship spring cleaning
yeah i love doing this we all have to do
it i love it so
if somebody's toxic if they don't add to
your life and
not even that like you're not even funny
if you're not funny or nice
what the [ __ ] are you waiting for
fighting yep why are you here if you
don't feed me make me laugh or [ __ ] me
why are you in my life
[ __ ] why are you taking up my energy
it's you're not wrong you're not wrong
but that was pretty blatant like
that's the way i have to equate it i had
one man that i was dating
and i traveled to see him and i'll never
forget i was like what are we gonna do
this weekend he's like well
i'm gonna feed you and i'm gonna [ __ ]
you and i was like
well i guess my work here is done did
you have a neck tattoo
in that order no actually you did oh my
god we got a matching tattoo
he does and he was jewish he's not
getting that cemetery
is there a heart do you see it here wait
is it here you don't have any hearts on
you wait wait wait
yeah it's right there okay
you traveled and got tattoos that trip
what state it was when i was living in
new york and i came here to la
oh l.a okay okay okay and i was gonna
get a tattoo
anyways but he was like i think he fell
in love with me and i was just there for
the food and the dick obviously
that that's all the only two things that
were on the menu i was like that's all
he asked for
that's why he presented by the way in
that order
food then dick food
over dick feed me [ __ ] me
don't [ __ ] me and feed me feed me [ __ ]
me
this is a polarizing topic cause a lot
of girls are scared to get [ __ ]
when they're fed because things are
gonna get moved around
but i don't have that problem so i just
gotta know
what if this because
if i'm thinking about i'm like all right
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna fly this girl
out she's really cool she's a comedian
yeah no all we're gonna do is bang i
hope she doesn't want to do it it's like
that
scene and [ __ ] uh have baked
like three dollars and eighteen cents
you wanna go for a walk
that's what i think was he super broken
was
i bought food before i went broke and i
have a dick
i don't have any other plans what is
what did he do for a living what
backwards hat did he tell you
i can't tell you what he did i had a
backwards hat you're going
to die he was the bouncer at a strip
male strip club
i'll give you three guesses okay
construction worker no way off oh [ __ ]
did he have anything to do with
entertainment yes oh [ __ ] okay was he a
key grip specific
thing who the [ __ ] says only people who
work in production
or on the screen like you and i know
what to keep thinking i'm like well he's
probably at least six weeks no
no so on the other side of the screen
a comic nope are you ready yeah i am
a ballroom dancer
how much did i hate myself stop he
said the word alvin ally is going on
i did he float he did he did his
his dick did the fox trot in my mouth
he the lord of the dance on my ass
he waltzed all over my [ __ ] stamp
yo what the [ __ ] he was a ballroom
dancer
how did you meet him i don't even know
at a wedding
and we just kind of had chemistry it was
just did he dance in front of you yeah
all right that was to say
if he danced in front of you in the wind
gotcha women
you know there's just certain things
like a lumberjack
a man who can like survive and like a
man knows how to dance
that just it's so funny that people say
that because dancing for guys is
supposed to be like the opposite like
that's not
a manly thing to do why are you dancing
you know what girls love it right
banging girls is a manly but the way to
get it is dancing but that's the wack
way and then it's like
yo you see that mexican guy spinning
he's banged four girls this week
here you see that mexican case that's my
grandpa he thought he was [ __ ] james
brown and [ __ ]
oh my god could your grandpa dance
that's amazing what dances would he do
only james brown dances ah so he was
like 16 he would hit the splits and [ __ ]
oh that's great he thought he was so
cool what's he was saying he was
thomas thomas oh you're uh no his rice
his was a
thomas oh thomas mine's thomas with the
name
okay no [ __ ] why is it every time i
speak less spanish than the [ __ ] guy
that's the white girl
last time i was ryan stickler and he
knew it was more spanish than i did i
bet you ryan sickler would clean
house if he did a spanish stand up i
could just see him like i'd be [ __ ]
funny
snagging spanish women too oh yeah
yeah it's the in those baby blues it's
the beard and the uh
the american oh the little crabs
you know mexican ladies oh you're
american the love of shellfish
[ __ ] he's got that company that sends
him shellfish from his hometown
yeah he gets crabs like flowing in like
i told him i'm like [ __ ] you
better get me some crabs
whoa that's tight it is because we were
talking about that we're talking about
that he's talking about like
some [ __ ] i don't i don't [ __ ] with
the ocean so i don't i don't blame you i
don't either
let's do too big 10 of it only 10 of it
have we discovered
i'm not down for the 90 to come up and
eat me for lunch
thank you i can't be in open water i
don't [ __ ] with it i don't [ __ ] with it
either and my friend's like you gotta go
to the beach it's
i will go to the beach up to my knees i
go up to my ankles and knees and that's
that's maybe past my knee done it's
terrifying
it's like what about when you step on
something oh i've and then you feel like
i lost it i freaked the [ __ ] out
you see those little sand crabs that go
under the sand no no no no no no dennis
i just saw those the other like
disgusting like last summer for the
first time the first time last summer
god it [ __ ] they look like
[ __ ] aliens they look like the
starship trooper bugs they do look like
the starship trooper bugs
they're disgusting and they've got you
know what else they look like those bugs
from
dark crystal that went through the
hallway oh that's where we break up
the dark crystal it's a 1980s fantasy
film by jim henson it will
change the puppet puppets uh
there's puppets but they're dark bro
bro the skessies and the dark christmas
that's why i haven't watched it because
[ __ ] david bowie's over here scaring
me in the labyrinth as a kid oh i love
the labyrinth i just watched that on bam
i'm going to do the dark crystal on bam
bam for this i love that bong's and
movies we should do it together
i am so [ __ ] down that sounds super
fun
we should totally do it together i do
that show every day in my house
we should there's like these beetles and
they come down the hallway that's what
those little bugs looked like
oh god that movie is so haunting that
was a kids movie dude
uh neverending story's scary that dog
that [ __ ] the falcore whatever the
good luck dragon
it was a dragon he had a dog face
it's the way his face moved with his
eyes remember
yeah he did kind of he had like those
mechanical yes the mechanical eyes
i have three of those that is you have
dogs yeah
oh my god are you a dog face that's a
dog face i would adopt that if i saw it
in the window oh for sure
what about this the creature the other
creature from the neverending story um
the only other thing is scary with the
laser eye like the wolf things
the wolf oh that's chasing his own wolf
yeah
what's his name like gork oh
damn gomork that's his name oh my god
again this is what my [ __ ] looked like
out of quarantine
it was gamork from neverending story you
ever been in the rainbow room
no that's around jeremy at the rainbow
room
that [ __ ] praying on ron jeremy
he did stand up for like
six minutes no when his knees [ __ ]
gave up
human hamster hung like a tongue like an
olympic baton
that is just nature [ __ ] with women
isn't it but a guy
looks like that's hung he's soaked oh my
god that's right he's in jail
he's in jail he got accused of raping
girls
what yes i don't believe it i think he
just pulls his dick out and go do you
guys know who i
am you you you want this why would he
have to rape
see faces 333 years okay
to your heart stops right why why
that just feels very egregious to say
yes
300 we get it you guys did your job
he's in jail how about we take the extra
years that
he would make him work outside well like
okay so he's gonna be alive like another
six minutes he looks like hell
he looked terrible so he's got pretty
much like 329 years and some change
left why don't we give that to the
people who are falsely
incarcerated for for cannabis crime and
give them those years to come out
because that would be too tight
whatever's left on their sentence those
years are gifted to them so they can
come oh
my god there's another movie a guy that
be makes crime
cremates crimes just so he can get his
brother out of jail that doesn't deserve
to beat him yes
and mark wahlberg and donny walmart he's
like guys my name is mark wahlberg
and i'm here guys what's up those flares
who's your male crush that's an actor
yeah you mean somebody i think that's
the [ __ ] yeah as a man who you're like
besides john stamos i know he's your og
but you and i are gonna fight over him
my favorite person ever is that uh i i
give i give good high fives i think me
and john's name should be like yo that
pop
yeah let's hang out and that's where it
would be a supernova of love when you
guys slap high five both our hair gets
longer
he loses all of his and you get more
whoa
whoa don't say that i'm sorry john that
would be amazing
that'd be wild you should grow out a
mullet bro no my hair gets too long too
fast i have to cut that [ __ ] all the
time but at least just for like prom
just for prom i was so i was not at pro
i didn't go to any [ __ ] it sounds
like it was brutal your your high school
no it was
it was cool i guess i just didn't [ __ ] i
was always on drugs
and selling drugs so i didn't show up to
school wow
you know what i mean isn't it amazing
how you've succeeded and didn't have
everybody in that system
did you were you one of those kids in
high school i drank a lot
in high school we were like a drinking
town and it's cold
it's cold that's why yeah it's different
it's hot as [ __ ] here yeah it's totally
different like the
definitely the environment and the
climate give birth to whatever the
vices are going to be and what can you
get your hands on and what you can get
your hands on yeah exactly
for kids and everyone in town's on meths
i'm like yo let's not go that route
find coke like yeah that [ __ ] smells
like meth cause it's cut
that's just what happened but i was one
of those kids i was really polite
i never got in trouble but i was always
sneaking [ __ ] around like
you were smart that goes back to my mom
she'll
[ __ ] me up my mom's mad scary it's still
wild though how much you're scared of
your mom and respect her and how
respectful you are
and yet you were like still i just snuck
it in that life
because she would never because if she
found out i was done so i would do
everything i wanted to do just sneak i
could i've told this before i would uh
go on the sunday before school with an
ounce for the week
or the day and i would tape sacks inside
the drain pipes
because it never rains so i never have
drugs on me
you know what i mean like okay again we
need to save this for the show
yeah this is like the pilot it was fun
this is you
yes that's how i just see you taping
them up like some like the reverse of
the clown that lives in the sewer you're
like the best
the nicest you're the nicest sewer clown
where's tim curry at oh god he played
the devil in legend
oh thank you so much you're welcome
thank you you're welcome nobody ever
[ __ ] knows he played the devil
great great role he's the scariest devil
of all time look at that
[ __ ] costume i bet you that devil
[ __ ] he definitely does
look at that face oh i bet you that
devil if you have not
seen legends so good free teeth
tom cruise tim curry it is so
super fantasy it's amazing and there's
like
little trolls when he puts them in the
pie scared the [ __ ] out of me as a kid
it's i'm going to go that's another one
i'm going to add to bam really good
i always talked about tim carrey hates
kids because in uh
home alone he's just after him calling
culkin as pennywise he [ __ ] eats kids
that's right and in legend he does not
like children he's trying to kill these
two who's the girl that girl was like a
one-hit wonder i feel like
no i think she's the girl from uh from
uh uh
ferris bueller right oh yeah you're
right i mean i wanted to be her
with the headdress and the [ __ ]
unicorn she looks when tom cruise dove
in the water to get that ring
i think i could do that [ __ ] so as a kid
you're like yo that's me no that's me
he told him in the water to get her
right meanwhile i can't get a dude to
get me an uber
oh damn this dude's jumping in the water
to get her running
with a [ __ ] loincloth mia sarah she's
beautiful
wow yeah she was the it girl for a hot
minute she still looks good she
looks like she does hair in wichita
kansas yeah she does she got that short
haircut she still looks good though
she's rocking it she'll definitely send
her a [ __ ] order back
i like women who look like they still
suck a dick i respect that i respect
that you and half the population
i just enjoy it i respect that vibe
how many times have i said dick and
quintessential that's fun
quintessential dick you're probably
second day i like you
damn that's a [ __ ] great opening line
you suck big still
i like you um damn i know we went off
topic and went to [ __ ] dicks i don't
even know how we got into
that but earlier you were talking about
how you dated a
[ __ ] ballroom dancer i didn't know
why did we get a high school menu of
hang out
and we got matching tattoos wow was the
first time you met him
no no no no him and i had sort of hung
out yeah i actually cheated on a
boyfriend with him
yeah i'm not gonna lie and act like i
didn't cheat well he sucks
i used to cheat when i was a little kid
cause i was hot and dudes wanted to get
with me and i was horny i used to cheat
when i was a little
kid 16. i mean you know i would assume
that there was some effect from being
raped as the first time having sex and
me
you know finding my sexuality through
that so
a lot of trial and error it's a trial i
mean i cheated on him i didn't like it
pros and cons yeah there's definitely
pros and cons to cheating
i don't do it anymore that was something
you know as a teenager
that was the old me yeah that was like
youth and
kind of maybe that was like the
equivalent of me doing drugs like that
was my rebellion
oh so that does make sense because i
tried not to be
hanging with any [ __ ] girls at all
wow because my mom and my dad had kids
so young oh that's oh
that's me i can't have that did you and
your dick have arguments a lot
no i imagine your dick being pissed bro
what are you doing no
i just went she's cool but she can also
get pregnant
i'm good that's smart i was very very
active you're probably the smartest drug
dealer i've ever met
very cautious because everyone has
merced has the highest rate of underage
uh
pregnancy in in the country in the
country for like four years straight
go merceda you guys are a champion there
is a daycare at our high school for the
kids
for the kids i'm just burp sorry
that's realistic it's [ __ ] insane
east campus has a daycare so when you
come to class as a 16 you drop your kid
off
i'm not mad at that though does that
make me a bad person no but it's like
you're not stopping the problem here
give there's a planned parenthood next
door to our high school
that gives free condoms still highest
pregnancy they should just move it into
the high school it's so dumb they should
walk around and pass them out
at [ __ ] recess at lunch
guys you want to get some plan b in in
some turkey slop
and play dodge ball after you take your
[ __ ] plan can you aim the dodge ball
of the girl's abdomen please oh
man she didn't want to take plan b so
this is plan c
what subject have we not hit today i
don't know that was forced abortion
um which is known as a fortune i like it
i like it oh my my favorite important
abortion
abortion no okay tell me on a scale of
one to losing isaiah rate your favorite
abortions
oh god no that's not what i meant to say
my favorite
no that's what i meant to say yeah tell
me your favorite portion i went with my
girlfriend to get a
birth control because she you know after
like three months you go back to planet
or
whatever and you get birth control and
as i'm sitting in the waiting room you
know because you're not allowed to go
back there
even before coven are you [ __ ] ready
no
she walks in i'm on my phone hitting my
emails and comments
what do you think happens outside fans
show up no
a [ __ ] abort anti-abortion rally
started and i could see one lady walking
and going why she got a sign
where's that lady gotta sign why do they
have big fans what are they doing out
there
right outside the front door and then me
being an [ __ ]
for the next 20 minutes till she came
out i'm just thinking of zingers
to say to them to say to them on the way
out like what can i say that's going to
make them go
you are i want them to go you're with
oh [ __ ] you
okay so as my girlfriend comes out
signing the paperwork and i've never
like hurried or like hurry the [ __ ] up
and sign that paper right now we gotta
go
like hurry up i have to do a type five
in the parking lot these [ __ ]
started leaving
i was in like 30 minutes they all had
their signs and their water coolers and
they just started walking down the
street with all their signs
oh my god that's a curb your enthusiasm
thank you
i was so sad that i didn't but my zinger
was when i walked out i was gonna go
they're making a killing in there that's
what i was gonna say to the
anti-abortion people
that should be an abortion clinic's
logan
that's funny we're making a killing in
here
put that on a billboard that's funny i
know it's horrible
we're making a killing in here making a
killing i need that on a t-shirt
right that's so again if you are
triggered by this it's probably because
you had an abortion or you know somebody
who did or you
just yourself or something or you're
[ __ ] not funny you're just not funny
there's that that comes down to it
offensive douchebag you just have no
sense of humor yes
they're the people that watched frasier
only
that's so specific and i can see the
person now watching frasier
oh my god long running show but that's
the beauty of comedy
there's something for everybody so much
like i don't watch
your uh whatever that [ __ ] famous
show is uh
how i met your oh no big bang is your
mother big bang theory
my mom loved it i never i never got it
i've never watched it i never got it
i don't get it my mom
i loved it my the funny parts are it's a
very specific but it doesn't mean
yeah it doesn't mean it's not funny it's
just not funny to me tina fey said
something i'll never forget and i'm
forgetting it right now
she said
she said just because you decide you
don't like something
doesn't mean it's empirically not good
yeah that's true
like with music like yo this is just
noise like but the apple loves it right
but
someone's dancing to and having a great
time you can't knock it
you can't because there's something for
everybody in this world in this life
and [ __ ] that you go nobody watches this
i guarantee you people watching people
are watching it is marty peeing in the
corner
oh no he's plugging his phone oh he
totally looked like he was pissed he was
pissing on the wall your producers
peeing on the wall
oh i wouldn't even be no i'd be mad but
i'd be astonished because yo you it did
look like you were pissing
never heard anyone say astonished in so
long i say it a lot when i see [ __ ] up
stupid [ __ ]
oh that's astonishing yeah because you
don't get to see things like that often
have you ever seen a ufo yeah
you have oh another government thing
sorry government i don't want to i
i'll talk i've seen a lot of [ __ ] i'm
gripping the table i've seen a lot of
[ __ ] because you're saying
merced is the number one place in the
planet for the most sightings in the in
history you guys have a lot of number
ones like why would you leave it sounds
like a championship town
just above us is cool and the rest is
drunk well also inside of you
damn a lot of pregnancies that was a
pregnancy joke no there's a lot of
pregnancies
there's there's actually unbelief
i'm one of the few people that don't
have a kid that in my
in high school graduating class i mean
not now in high school graduates are you
sure you have sperm
yes i just don't want it based on male
fertility i just don't want the i just i
can't
you saw my cousin's um child you're
awesome cousins baby the gerber baby
is literally it's got a head of hair
like it has a roth ira and a yacht
like a zoolander he's a zoolander it is
i said it seems
i'm so i'm still not child safe it is so
that thing was so cute
he was awesome but i don't want a baby a
full head of hair
i've never seen a head of hair like that
on a grown man
right and he had like it's all squashed
over to the side i saw his ass wake up i
look down
it is perfect terrace he's so cute that
thing hurt my ovaries
yeah i know i heard you say when you
walked in oh they were palpitating i was
like what is that getting away from me
that's how i feel too i just can't do it
i can't do it i
i'm way too selfish of my time but i
think you and i are put on this earth to
save the earth
as well as homosexuals oh this is
a better outcome that's about and that's
another thing to talk about when people
get upset like
you might be gay if you don't like gay
people it's something you can't do
yourself because i had friends that um
they had super bad anger problems and
later find out like
oh you came out oh that makes sense well
that makes sense that makes sense
yes because when people would say [ __ ] i
don't like
gay people i don't know [ __ ] that
they're weird the thing that you're
[ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly is the key to your true
[ __ ] gay bro and there's nothing
wrong
i don't think okay i have i have a
friend that is
anti gay to the max and it's on rebel
i've had five hour arguments with him
and now people are going to ask how can
you be friends with someone like that i
want to know how because
just because someone has a fault doesn't
mean they're a bad person right so
just ignorance as i call mike yo you're
so and he goes
i know but i don't like what i don't
like all right
and i i don't know why i whispered we're
stupid no and i even thought like
did you have sex with somebody in high
school because he's from atlanta and
he's like it's hypersexual
it's like he that's what he calls it's
called hypersexual work
it's in your face people oh no just sex
in general
in atlanta because they have the most
strip clubs ever oh god i went to the
claremont lounge in atlanta that's a
great strip club they've got like 80
year old strippers
they come out with moo moos and there's
this one lady called barbie with the
biggest boobs i've ever seen she smashed
beer cans with them what the [ __ ] oh
that's that bug
oh you hear that train what's happening
it's actually above us are my shrooms
kicking in i hear a tree and there's a
bug in my face
at the same time at the same time it's
called care packages
and they come from time to time ah and
uh
oh my god is that the polar express it's
tom hanks
ethel's gonna be an actor and he's not
even in the movie i know but his
face is actually he is in the movie they
they did that
wipeover scanner scanner darkly i've
only watched it once i was drunk i
didn't finish it well i feel like
yeah it's like is this movie affected or
am i that drunk
it [ __ ] my head when i was drunk it
was kind of strange yeah can we talk
about robert downey jr
what a badass what about him ah just
everybody was sucking dick
less than zero well there goes my
brother
your second day for cocaine and then
died
one of the first movies i ever watched
my mom did he really
you know was it a good movie i've never
seen them okay i'll watch it
he plays robert downey jr
[Laughter]
he's hitting crack right there talk
about somebody
who has gone to the depths and totally
you totally redeemed yourself and
totally redeemed
yourself oh dumb and dumber i think i've
met my cinematic man i came to the place
all right i grew up on movies i always
say cable guy but i'm not weird
oh my god yeah that's a good [ __ ]
movie that's a
i'm excited to see it lesser than less
than zero
yes i've heard of it i think it's a
classic isn't it kind of a classic
early 90s and i watched it i was a kid i
go why is he
people put dicks in their mouth and
that's what i was thinking as a kid like
why is he too
i didn't understand oh that's
interesting like think about your
introduction into sexuality i think mine
was like that
shoddy music video where she's like a
mermaid and she's making out
underwater with the guy that that
hook when he's kissing the [ __ ]
mermaid underneath and like
he's like finger blasting the mermaid
underwater and my dad walked in he's
like he turned it off and yelled at me
i can't watch this it's inappropriate
and it was just like look how stupid he
looks
she's like in a fish tank at a seafood
restaurant
she had a place it's not even like that
sexual literally looks like she's in a
fish tank not sexual at all
no but my dad was so pissed and that's a
thing like
how you're raised and how people react
to things like sex
affect you were your parents tripped
were they what strict
my mom was they definitely were the
dichotomy of each other my dad was the
fun
you know i could get away with rebelle
relationship and my mother
had to set the rules because he was that
way so she had to be the bad guy uh
malcolm in the middle hal and lois yeah
she had to be that and
it's good thing she was because i chose
comedy and not
strip stripping no it's fine
it's your boss i love yours are [ __ ]
awesome they're the greatest i think
every woman should learn how to strip
coolest
yeah they're great uh i it's always a
funny joke like
that they don't have dad figures but
that's the whole joke
that's the only joke i have a joke in my
set about how i think every woman should
strip or at least learn
to like have that dominance and control
of your sexuality and to pay your rent
to make some real money although i know
a lot of strippers are have been in the
past
terrible with money just buying their
boyfriend's houses in florida
yo what are you doing any time you're
buying your boyfriend
stuff re-evaluate yourself re-evaluate
your life
for real quit buying lance motorcycles
that is the that's hoverboard that's the
name monster energy drink
doesn't need to be bought in bulk
all strippers have a fugly ass white
boyfriend with [ __ ]
norcal stars in their elbows he looks
like a budget eminem from his town
thank you look like actual stan
federline they all look like a bunch of
federer
talking about him the other day and how
he's finessed the [ __ ] out of britney
spears
he really played the [ __ ] out he played
the [ __ ] out of her he got her he
nba girlfriend heard thank you
he got himself pregnant no talent but a
backup dancer
he was chair oh my i can't that was he's
not even
i mean i'm a i i don't know how girls
think that guy
looks like edward furlong now edward
furlong looks
terrible i don't know i mean he was cute
for five minutes
kevin federline and then he's like kid
rock but buffer yeah he looks like kid
rock after a bender
yeah oh that's him now oh where
whoa he looked like like a rapper from
the 90s that didn't make it
yes he's got a nirvana shirt under it's
like bro why are you still dressing the
way you used to dress you gotta grow up
marty just put now yes kevin federline
now
whoa no whoa walmart special
yo that's kevin he pulled britney spears
he looks like a creature he
get the [ __ ] sorry kevin lines mean to
attack you but yeah sorry bro
yeah get it together together you're
smoking cigs in a white tee and
flip-flops you're [ __ ] garbage and
you know if you can't make it it's your
fault you should have sold all the [ __ ]
brittany got you
and put it into bitcoins he gets a
alimony from her
every month oh my god that's right girls
got him listen when he says if you're
buying [ __ ] for your boyfriends it's not
reciprocated and it's not
enough is enough yep [ __ ] should be
paid
enough of this [ __ ] i love strippers i
like his potential
no more [ __ ] potential if you feel
like you gotta spackle walls
or redo the foundation and make him
better you gotta move on
yes there's some exceptions there's some
exceptions
towards like but he's an artist and he's
making it no
nope go sleep on your uncle's couch god
damn it
sorry marty i'm speaking for myself
you've got north carolina do you have
north carolina tattoos oh yeah i'm
[ __ ] covered in them
i can't see
are on that ten dollar bracket oh i'm
not even in the fancy bracket you're not
even there yet it's on his lower back
no no more of this no more supporting
men but i'm i'm a grown ass [ __ ] so
it's not it would be unattractive and
rude for me to do that now
so it's you got to come to me correct
you have to come with
your own payment plan for your life i
can't be your payment yes so
for you being a comedian and a girl
because mo you don't hear those two
words put together
often and you're like it's just it's
like a
stereotype oh she's a female comic
it was it how you thought no that's how
people think they'll think about it i
know think about it so
how do you deal with that but you know
that you're funny inside and when you go
up like don't worry i'll go on stage and
be fine
there's a reason why you get invited to
places and you get work i'm saying
when you started is this a disadvantage
just i know it shouldn't be
it's like being a white rapper as being
a female comic is being a white rapper
he said that is
so funny i never i never thought of it
as a disadvantage
i never saw it as a crutch and i never
used it
to exploit it to
make it work for me intentionally yeah
because whenever i was up on stage i was
always like oh
okay this is my time to do my thing
exactly i never had like a competitive
thing like oh she's this and she's that
i just
i just was a comedian i never thought
about it being a
you know a disadvantage there are things
just being a woman that make it
difficult to exist
like the constant dicks and you know men
look at the concept just dick stick
stick stick stick sticks you must get it
the worst
i mean i'm just happy i'm still getting
it no i'm talking about what that [ __ ]
stops i'm gonna be like
i'm gonna go how many comic dudes are
just
like all right girl there's a lot of
girls here yeah but it's flipped
now you're the comic and are these dudes
just being creeps after the show
well like we talked about how my one of
my pages is messed up it does make you
more vulnerable to things happening and
people being a little bit more leechy
and messages like i get but that's
i guess being a woman is the [ __ ] up
part first and then being
a somewhat famous person adds another
level
of creepery you know what i'm saying
when you first started out when you were
just getting going a lot of creeps
a lot of creeps pretty blonde girl young
doing standing a lot of creeps
but that the creeps started before stand
up oh for sure i'm saying it's just
it's just you're now literally home yeah
it gets magnified and also men
who try you i'm not the one i
am not the one i i like i grew up in a
very like i told you
socioeconomic diverse place i
went to public school my mother raised
me to be strong i'm not the one
so i my favorite thing in life is when
guys
in the industry would lead and
think that they could play one over on
me
and i just would say something or do
something to let them know i'm not the
one
yeah you're gonna have to get sally
behind me
because you're going to pay me what's on
the paper and you're going to do what
you said you were going to do
and you're going to stop looking at me
this way or touching me or making
comments
all these things are going to stop you
just it it becomes
a tedious responsibility but women have
to dig down deep and find that within
themselves
so they carry themselves in a way so
they don't get penetrated in a parking
lot
yes but also beyond that we have to do
better by
our men we have to let our men know
tommy stop being a [ __ ] pervert
i think guys need to check more guys
yeah just check them
out make fun of them like oh you're a
[ __ ] creep huh don't just get out of
here
that's the conversation to have has to
happen because it's always been women
you know i know i'm saying for women to
find their voice but it's always been
the responsibility of the woman to deal
with
everything that goes on in society
instead of for us checking our friends
check your brothers and your uncles and
your cousins and your dad and
your friends check them it would just
i feel like it's like past check if it's
part of your family it's more like
well now i don't chill with them on
christmas yes they're a [ __ ] weirdo
and i can't
cousin or not or a brother or not like
it's it's such a
weird it's hard for people i think it's
easier for people to go well it's just
some girl i don't know versus well it's
my brother
yeah your brother's also a [ __ ] gross
[ __ ] yeah there's a lot of thing
people have to deal with in life that
make it difficult because
society doesn't really give us the tools
or the conversation to make it so that
it's weird to bring it up right it's
it's taboo yeah so you just have to deal
with it just you know
the more taboo thing is what we're
talking about i know but
i think it's important for the platform
like
someone's going to watch this someone
listening or watching
is going through what we're discussing
of course and they don't know what the
[ __ ] to do
and that's the other side of like being
funny and all of that like
bringing some levity to the situation
and the scenario and let people know
that
hey there are ways to get through this
[ __ ] yeah and you're not the only one
most people just wanna know they're not
the only one when they're going through
all this traumatic [ __ ]
super true though if i saw somebody
going through the same [ __ ] i was going
through as a kid like okay well
it happens then i don't think anyone
went through what you went through i'm
just saying like
being a poor kid and [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
sucks that's just not fun
i see the opening scene of you at your
school and
everyone is speaking spanish no and you
are just like
hola no they they at least know spanish
it's just
okay it's a it's like a segregated ass
town this is all mexican kids and
asian kids and then there's four black
kids in town and there's
35 white kids only but they go to the
other school okay that's the narrative
that's a voiceover of the pilot episode
and there's four black kids in town and
then there's eight white kids
and me yep underneath the [ __ ]
where did you say you put it drain pipes
and the drain pipes yeah drain pipes uh
the wood from wood shop
was good because it never got moved and
it doesn't rain so you might take two
steps stick your arm
pallet oh no i'm gonna be checking every
i'm gonna be looking in every drain pipe
on the way out of here
you know get some diseases yeah you can
find you know
the meth head living in there well you
know what i
guarantee you there's drugs and drain
pipes in l.a because it's so
[ __ ] it's the method
of selling weed at school it's like
don't have it with you stupid
so that's kind of like a a known thing
in the drug world no i don't know i just
thought that it would be smart because i
think it's pretty intelligent
it's just smarter because like i said it
goes back to my mom if i get caught she
didn't only smoke weed i was a 4.0
student and [ __ ]
until high school i never suspected you
no and they didn't you see my spit went
right there
i didn't but one time i did it i think
last week and i
saw that [ __ ] hit the camera how the
[ __ ] did that happen
from all the way over here so yes i know
what you're saying it's the
it's the light backlight my spit right
here covered free no covert you're all
right no code
we'll be all right i'll [ __ ] i got
sick in december and that [ __ ]
sucked dude you got the coven in
december it took you down hard
how many days were you down 17 days
that [ __ ] sucked should i be close to
this microphone no you're fine you're
fine
i'm like how how many days were you down
it was uh
well it was more like 12 i was sick and
i'm like a week after like get the [ __ ]
away from me everybody because if i get
you sick i feel terrible did you get
anyone sick
nine go around no single person that's
why i'm here sally
tony cheryl these are the people you got
sick and we're
here oh [ __ ] yeah you breathe in your
apartment and it went outside and
i'm suing you do you just describe my
whole other side of the family marcia
and ron and melissa
yeah my whole other side of the family
is white wow jewish people
and um no it's it's a [ __ ] long story
it's so
it's a long story you're going to put
down on paper and you're going to sell
it to netflix
that's fine if they just want to cough
it up oh they'll cough it up
cough it up because they will cough it
up [ __ ] i'm executive producer
co-creator co-founder
i made it up on my podcast which by the
way is the most white thing to do
is for me to tell hi i'm the executive
producer
this is hip hop music presented by me
hi i'm stacy smith and i wrote this
story about a lady boys
i used to have another character called
the 42 year old white woman and they
call him karen's now
yeah that's right but that was my exact
description i used to say for when i was
a kid
speak to the manager yeah because i had
one as
a health teacher mrs [ __ ] you always mad
right they're always mad
no she just didn't like me oh she would
make fun of me whenever she looked like
jealous
she was a [ __ ] because she liked you
trust me
i would never show up to class i still
pass so she was always upset
she was at home fiddling the diddle
thinking about your face
and hated herself for it [ __ ] hope
not she looks like the lady that made
suits on the incredibles
well i'm going to check her journals and
see if it says otherwise oh you know her
personally
i'm going to check her journals that she
keeps in my bedroom i'm going to check
the papers i'm going to go to the papers
on this one
um one other thing i forgot we never
even smoked this joint
which is fine with me i just completely
forgot that i had it
i completely forgot we didn't even swap
that's the most
stoner move ever you guys i just don't
you forgot to smoke weed
and how do you forget something like
this i don't know i just forgot
i forgot how do you
truly forget something like this it's
all purple weed i don't know if you like
purple wheat purple weed
i mean rainbow any color i'm not here to
judge well
it makes people sleepy green yellow
purple the yellows
whatever i'ma like this real quick okay
i'm gonna light this one i like that you
have these ashtrays these are the
ashtrays found in an rv of a man who
beats his wife oh for sure
in a sticky hotel room of six yeah yeah
this is a motel 6
mid 90s waking up sweaty 100 this is the
econo lodge special
thank you exactly you know how many
times i've stayed there on the road
there's like so
trash i found a full syringe of heroin
in my bed once
was that because you brought it in your
bag no
i saw a tweaker walk by i almost
considered selling it to him i'm not
kidding
enough to pay for the room i'm not
kidding this is a couple years ago made
myself choke
you're seeing four rooms okay so
remember the
the hooker in the bed i don't remember
that part oh well there was a syringe in
the bed
and anywhere i go i search everywhere
because i had hella pounds of weed on me
and i was staying in hotels and like you
know let me search make sure there's
some
creeps in here is that quentin it's four
rooms
yes and so i need to i need to watch
that and zero
dart crystal no zero dark thirty zero
zero oh less than zero zero dark there
you mixed all the movies you talked
about is that a movie
lesson zero is zero dark thirty it
probably is it sounds like a war
[ __ ] ben affleck or something oh god
you're such bad ben affleck what's with
him and
dunkin donuts lately is he hella fat too
he loves dunkin donuts
my friend carly talks about it all the
time he's always got a bag of dunkin
donuts not even good
they're not good you know what hours
after you bring them home they'll chip a
tooth
they'll chip a tooth i know it sounds
crazy because i'm fat but i don't [ __ ]
with donuts
i don't give a [ __ ] you're not supposed
to call yourself fat
i'm just facing reality okay i'm just
talking about you
you're not fat i'm overweight
tremendously and we'll just leave it at
that
um you got you got more for loving
that's all
there we go like it's harder to hug you
but you know
i beg to differ it's so much
better to hug a fat person you get in
there you get in the nooks and crannies
it's the warmest hug you'll ever have
that's not ever hug a skinny bony [ __ ]
oh my god i'm shivering oh
i've got covered just thinking about it
i got covenant malnourished
and i sent my food back um what the [ __ ]
was i just saying
i don't know holy we are not even stoned
yet i completely forgot what it was
about
yeah this is dope as usual yep that's
pretty much what happens yeah
do you keep stuff in there oh this is
actually called a poison ring
women back in the day would drug men
you know and take their money i call
them heroes
[Laughter]
move this water to the other side of my
[ __ ] leg i call them hero
that's [ __ ] cool they're my cruel
intentions and that lady had the
coke in the crowd exactly what drug what
would be the best to put in here though
ecstasy okay you got any i don't oh [ __ ]
i don't i was looking to fill this puppy
up on the way home the only reason i
wore it here is that
hoping you could stick something in it
that is [ __ ] cool thank you
yeah i'll have to find some ecstasy send
me some
send yourself to the people i'm telling
to the people oh actually probably not a
good idea it's utterly illegal
send me access to hearing poorly legal
federally illegal oh that's a great
title for the show
fairly legal i like that i like that too
i like that a lot i can't wait to watch
a show when it comes out i know you're
going to make one
we will we'll make one for you i know
you are going to be [ __ ] awesome
do you remember what we were saying
before um
[Music]
i gotta be honest i [ __ ] i can't
remember
i it was i was i was saying i'm sure it
was great it was something we're talking
about fat
talk about fat stuff oh talk about how
bad ben affleck is and eating oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so he's all fat now that
sucks i don't know if he's fat
necessarily but he's eating doughnuts
and he's from boston right he is from
boston and he's also smoke uh
smoking drinking a lot of starbucks
so to me it sounds like either he's
going through some [ __ ]
or he's stoned i i hope it's still the
second
i hope it's the second one because ben
affleck he's
he's just one of those guys you got to
keep around because one day when he's
older he's like yo it's ben affleck and
he plays a [ __ ] pothead now it's
perfect i bet you he's don't i bet he
smokes
yeah he was in jane son bob part one i
mean uh
uh jay and signed bob and he played a
[ __ ] stoner so he's got to be fri
he's friends with kevin smith he's
probably getting high that's a good good
reference there i didn't even realize he
was in that
yeah he played like he played the donnie
uh wahlberg
part he played for he got he got paid
for 30 minutes of work that day
were you mad at him when he did gigi or
what was it i never watched it
was it him and um jeffrey lopez what
were they called they were called
geely geely but they called them
something
uh benefer benefer
stop they called them
benford yo do you hear about a-rod and
j-lo apparently they're working it out i
don't know why i'm bringing celebrity
gossip here
they're married a-rod and j-lo you
didn't know they were married don't pay
attention god bless your heart
i love that you're like what yeah i just
know he's a really talented person
like we have a black president you
missed that
[ __ ] you missed that [ __ ]
i missed a lot of [ __ ] i missed a lot
i'm gonna save most of this
because i there's a vehicle i'm getting
in do you think you don't even have to
smoke it
that's why i just said it i took a
little sample of it
um but what i'm going to do is smoke it
at your house
save this for bam and spoken at your
house can i steal your lighter
take it i got some do you smoke bongs
obviously
those are all bongs in those boxes so i
got you on whatever size
i need a new ball gotcha yes
this is the greatest it's like a fun
warehouse day
ever gene wilder here to scare us with
good acting
and gene wilder's my favorite actor of
all time really yeah i have a tattoo
of willy wonka on my arm written in my
mom's handwriting good [ __ ]
really yeah i met him once where
i got to know the story where i gotta
know oh my god do you love gene wilder
i love him he's so he had alzheimer's
yeah that's why stop acting
yep he didn't want to scare the kids
crazy right
also so selfless yeah but he it's also
like yo you're in blazing saddles you're
in willy wonka
you can hang it up you're [ __ ] yeah
you're done after that
what was his first movie bonnie and
clyde that was his first movie yep
and then he did frisco kid is great i
have it so
[ __ ] funny blazing saddles was my
dad's
favorite [ __ ] movie so racist and
perfect
watch it now because it was made in the
70s 70s
and mel mill brooks mel brooks literally
was like
we're gonna make the movie to end all
movies and it happened
45 years ago 45 years ago
and today it is
if you watch it i'm sure you're going to
be triggered
it's just but it's funny it's just meant
to be funny it's
very racist the baked bean scene and
we're we're all white women at is the
most iconic [ __ ] catchphrase from a
[ __ ] movie of all time
when it's so funny it's where all the
white women at where all the white women
at the [ __ ] black sheriff he walks
into town
you know it's just a good movie overall
it's a good [ __ ] movie it really
really is
it's [ __ ] great it's so great i'm so
glad you know all the movie and nobody
ever gets my [ __ ]
young frankenstein that's great young
frankenstein i didn't realize that
igor doesn't look like that in real life
and that's what i know
is that actors marty feldman i think i
didn't know that actors
change up like that because they're not
see this is a problem with hollywood
they don't
hire real gimps
find an igor go under the
go near the la river and you'll find one
who's been
who turned into one because you didn't
book him on any of the [ __ ] gigs
you didn't book him because he had a
natural hump in pulp fiction the [ __ ]
was actually a [ __ ]
really no i'm kidding oh [ __ ] no you
[ __ ] got you
no but could you imagine this [ __ ]
you gotta hire real actors i'm saying
like
what did you type in we all know where
is the [ __ ] where are the gimp's
representation
i want to know what that fool does for a
living oh the [ __ ]
oh yeah people that do [ __ ] like that
you know they're like business people or
something weird
or that's or that is their business it's
a hitchhiker who fell victim
to oh that's right oh that's right oh
they killed him with a sword i feel bad
now that pulp fiction
is i watched that when i was five or six
and it [ __ ] me
up i know that movie's so classic i just
rewatched kill bill
it's so good i watched both too
they're just good [ __ ] movies such
good revenge films there's so many kill
bill 2
it's such a beautiful part 2 is better
part 2 is better it was supposed to be
one movie
the part 3 is supposed to be coming out
it was supposed to be two years ago
yeah because they're waiting for the
little girl to be 18 so she could play
the
actress to try to kill uma thurman and
regina
regina's daughter that's that's what
we're talking about that's
the whole thing about their like ten
more years is going to come out and i
was like 14 going
i ain't waiting for that [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] 18 years ago
in the kitchen when she was like oh like
if you ever you ever have something to
say about it
you know where to find it yes oh that's
gonna be a good [ __ ] movie
that's the girl oh three c
c to play that wait so they got a
different actor oh they did see
hollywood that first one probably turned
you know probably turned into a hot mess
because how hollywood is
not everyone gets a turnout like drew
barrymore she made it through the maze
it's [ __ ] cool man true barrymore is
she's funny she was doing cocaine at
like seven
i know and hollywood was fine with it
they were fine with it they were
fine with that shit's crazy this is why
it's dangerous it's crazy
to within certain expect
expecta uh exceptions to
like try to totally take people down for
something they did in the past
like for what they said because
society's different times moves it
evolved over time
you know it's it's such a slippery slope
there's such a fine line between that
whole thing of like trying to take
people down
and today's standards are different of
course they don't match yesterday's
rules
exactly so it's a hot it's a hard topic
it's a hard situation it has to
you have to evolve with what's going on
can you imagine if you're bear more
if that was happening today a
six-year-old doing drugs and hanging out
at parties that's the [ __ ] studio 54.
what the hell she was partying at studio
54 before she had her period
yes that's so crazy and creepy it's
crazy i think that's why steven
spielberg became her godfather to
try and like save her from that life
i hope so but she turned out pretty damn
good i mean that girl
she's cool she's cool she's funny she
came she just was like yep
went through a bunch of [ __ ] she has a
new show oh uh a new
that you're bearing a new movie i just
watched a new movie with drew barrymore
that was so
[ __ ] funny and really good she's
super famous
and she has her stunt double take over
her life
it was [ __ ] good it was really good i
just watched the other day
what's it called i'll find out 50 first
movies
yeah my 51st first [ __ ] movie what
the [ __ ] is the movie called
that's what we were talking about what
you were like holy [ __ ] full circle
i said who's your favorite male actor
that you would want to that was [ __ ]
an
hour ago totally evaded the question no
it's adam sandler
i just thought drew barrymore because
anderson is my favorite person ever so
that's that's my answer you have a crush
on adam sandler he's a cool
best friend yeah he he really did it
right he did hollywood right
so much snl when i was young oh god that
that whole era
with him on it was just saturday live
was
the bomb and then tv came and i was like
matt tv and then i went backstage live
yeah mad tv
remember in living color of course you
can fire marshall
j.lo was one of the fly girls yes yeah i
remember that my mom like jayla these
dance moves
there were so many i mean not these
exact ones that's [ __ ] tai bo
they were doing tai bo in the back of
[ __ ] they literally were doing tai bo
they were to a b to a b let's be real
but that was the most of the dancing in
the 90s was like tai bo
and lifting your knees
anything will smith was doing on [ __ ]
fresh pranks oh my god
oh my god speaking of the [ __ ] 90s we
came up with a little segment and i want
to
ask you about it marty came up with this
and it's so [ __ ] good and i love it
marty what a genius this segment's
called who were you in the 90s
right okay and basically i'm gonna ask
you things and you pick between
and this is a good judge of character on
people like when you walk up and go
you know legend you know tim curry was
the level
you know you get that connection like
yeah yeah good [ __ ] so this is the
perfect way i think to do it and it's
it's actually
works right like perfect right now so
let's just hop
into it speaking of these actual people
okay okay
okay so who were you in the 90s adam
sandler jim carrey jim carrey
yeah 100 so fast oh he to me
is one of the greatest
actors and comedians of all time i feel
like uh comedians are the best dramatic
actors yeah they can emote
those emotions they have a direct line
to them
it's weird it is weird robin williams
that's what i always compare it to
that's the person i always get
i mean i just watched mrs doubtfire on
my flight yesterday and i was like it
still holds
up he tried to kill pierce brosnan let's
just say that right now
he tried to murder him in a restaurant
he really did pierce was piercing his
wife and he was
but his her husband was also dressed as
a woman and he had no idea
and she was just desperate times call
for desperate measures how bad do you
want to see your kids
that's true tuck your dick tuck your
dick down your dick tell your brother to
make you faces
yes burn your your boobs on
on the [ __ ] uh
first day as a woman i'm already feeling
hot flashes first there's one oh my god
i'm gonna watch that movie now it's so
so you have to watch it it's so funny
dude
it's so i love the gay ass brother he's
so happy he wants to make him a [ __ ]
woman
i just he's like i just love it i
thought you never asked have you ever do
you like robin williams then
i loved love you ever seen i still love
him what dreams may come
what dreams may come so yes
keep a good in place god for some reason
what dreams may come
i just there's nothing to be said about
it good
there's nothing to be said about the
same [ __ ] path
it's i'm gonna i'm gonna watch i'm gonna
watch that again i'm gonna get stoned
and go watch that
few moves i kept on i'm gonna order
pizza i must i have to save this for bam
because i already said i would i
committed
i'm gonna smoke another blunt that i
have and watch that
that's a good [ __ ] movie
awakenings
awakenings i've seen i can't i can't
remember it like oh where are my glasses
they're on your head
okay i can't do it it's heavy i watched
it so long ago
but awakenings is a perfect example of
what you're talking about
a comedic actor well no this is
different a comedian being able to be a
dramatic actor
awakenings is like just such a heavy
film he still was able to bring
that emotional depth to it just shows
you know robert downey robert de niro
and i think he has a deal well based on
a true story yeah the guy has
some sort of disease i forget what
disease it was it may be a
neurodegenerative disease
something where he's going to
deteriorate really young
i don't remember it brutal i can't do it
step by step brutal brutal
yeah and i love robin williams he to me
he just
epitomizes damn that's good the type of
career that
is a dream just a dream career
he was able to do so much and it's such
a shame how it all transpired but i kind
of understand why he did what he did
not that i'm defending taking your own
life but
for him in that time he must have you
know going through it he must he was
going through it
you know and he left a great body of
water genie
and you're that sad then yeah
something's wrong something's wrong he's
strong
genie yeah oh my god i just i don't even
recognize my own voice just now
he's teeny he brought such life to that
role
world according to garp world according
to who to garp
carp garp g-a-r-p i did why did what i
don't
know
williams i don't remember it but i've
seen it 28-ish
world according to guard world according
to garbage oh toy
remember a toy
if you think about the amount i have now
i have to watch this look at john
lithgow playing a chick
look at him it's really oh it's so good
m g if this reminds me of tu wong fu
thank you for everything i love that
movie so [ __ ]
much [ __ ] i didn't know it wasn't snakes
for so long wesley snyder
knows what his life for so long because
i was four or five watching and go
that's that [ __ ] from ghost but
he's got a wig on right
and john leguizamo was almost so
talented
i know for hold on patrick swayze is the
[ __ ]
the ladies man of the 90s wesley snipes
is
played the biggest action hero new jack
city and also doesn't like to pay taxes
i don't blame him crazy of all the
things you go to
blade goes to jail for it was [ __ ]
tax evasion i don't play
just do another blade [ __ ]
you guys are great you've done so much
for us yeah no john goes almost in that
[ __ ] rizzo from greece
rizzo it's a good movie it's a good good
movie
classic yeah it's really good i watched
that one the only reason i have all
these
movie references because my mom it's the
only good thing she had a different the
only reason i did it was my dad
yeah that's the only good thing i had
yeah was watching this [ __ ]
um stan that was a segment so we rent we
ran the same
that was a segment no there was one
question out of 30. this is supposed to
be rapid fire
it's supposed to be backwards okay okay
no it's my fault
okay i have total you went jim carrey
you ready yeah you're ready you win
rapid fire okay tupac or biggie smalls
oh
tupac i can't go that route but
i love him but i love biggie more get
ready for that really hard one
yeah step by step or family matters
i gotta go oh no it's too hard family
matters
because jaleel is my friend but also it
was a great show julia white yeah
i named my weed piper steve stefan
arkell because it was the coolest pipe
oh you have to send him one i'm like you
have to give him
i know it's i don't make him i'm bought
a piper's [ __ ] 12 years ago oh
you named it stephen stephen
well of course i remember everything can
we talk about the episode where he
played stefan
urkel and the aunt with the wig and fake
boobs
i don't think like he's like my girl
jaleel's an icon
i forgot about that he's such a good
actor like that
forgot about that dude he played three
different characters maybe even four
the nerdy girl and the nerdy girl oh you
played
as his cousin mabo mabel they worked him
myrtle myrtle that's her name oracle
myrtle
urkel and he played he played like
five or six characters on that show that
when i when he played stuff on our kill
i found that's the day i realized and
ona
i'm sorry what were you saying oh wow
see that didn't hit me very hard like
the myrtle girl
that's the day i realized that he's an
actor yeah because i thought steve urkel
was steve urkel
me too and then when he played stuff
arnold kell then i realized so you're
cool in person
yes in real life he's the coolest [ __ ]
me up we just talked about this last
episode
he's the greatest he's one of the
greatest i was at a
party i was smoking weed because i
[ __ ] hate being at [ __ ] parties
i just do and i always smoke it makes me
feel so much worse
i feel better i like like yes i'm spoken
by myself i feel great too
look at all the characters he played
stefano
myrtle urkel bruce lee erkel
i remember that episode he was all like
skinny chested i remember that episode
yes i remember that one um i met him i
was at a party
and i was standing in a circle with some
people that were like yo what's up we
follow him like oh thanks man appreciate
it
and it's like yeah we want to work we do
we do this company in my head i'm like
all right
you want to have a business meeting at a
park oh god this is not real
but i was just being nice and you know
and then he moved to the side
and i see i go this [ __ ] julia white
i'm like
get the [ __ ] out of here it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is one of my i love him and
david faustino
to the [ __ ] max that's hilarious
because as a kid i grew up
like oh he was the coolest he was the
brother everyone wanted
he never got to bang any of the girls
but the episode he did with the girl
with the braces
talk about a show that could not be made
today
married with children no ma'am i'm sorry
it is
tell me it's not a top five most
offensive shows ever
i was going to say well written
offensive but i love my uh well no my
fiance
is she's never seen the show
we started the show over recently
everyone always
oh it's so offensive to for you today
but then it was entertaining it was fun
yo the daughter she's openly banging
that the older man that's right
yeah that was it yes
that was his mom does he have money what
was his name on the show what was the
dad's name
oh you're talking about al bundy al
bundy that's my sister's tagger name
such a such a character and also a
representative of a lot of men and women
just broken down man every day man
and can we talk about how um christina
applegate
thank you has she stayed relevant
she is such a good actress dead to me
there there's another one she's that's a
good show that's a great show a really
good show in the girl from freezing
geeks linda
can candle candlelight catalana link
canolini i just know she's from uh
cuddling freaks and geeks and uh great
actress grandma's boy
they're so good together that show is
really a good show and then when it gets
deep and serious it gets [ __ ] deep
it gets deep and serious yeah but
they're able to go there they're both
such good actresses
damn we did it again oh [ __ ] are we
supposed to be rapid fire okay go
go go go go i've been holding this
because i can't wait to finish okay
mario or donkey kong mario thank you
same there's no
comparison this is a hard one
michael jackson or michael jordan
michael jackson all day i'll every day
everybody else to listen to his music
i'm so sorry if that happened to the
children i really don't believe it but i
love him
you just said a whole [ __ ]
pharmaceutical commercial right now
[Laughter]
i don't gotta be the one with the
children i am playing thriller album
until i die
i'm just gonna say it whether naughty
[ __ ] damn kids
the music was really really good that
music was so
good it's still good that's like saying
something
it's good it's just a good and the way
dance is in that move in that video is
iconic it's bomb okay it's like jfk
we're never gonna know
we're never gonna know some shady [ __ ]
went down you haven't seen the video
i've seen the video no the new video
that got released oh no there's another
one
[ __ ] i redact everything i just said
we'll get into it after i'll show you
the video
we're doing exactly what we did before
it's bad
rapid fire i'm focused ready go let me
read it again okay ready
oh sunny d or chocolate milk nest quick
with this
quick all day the light skin rabbit all
day yeah
[ __ ] your sunny d that fake ass orange
juice fake
[ __ ] doesn't even taste like an orange
nope tastes like a like a tic tac
it does taste like an orange tic tac it
tastes like a tic tac with medicine in
it
it does take your sunny d dump that [ __ ]
in the drain where it belongs
ness quick quick don't even show me the
quick can
oh the can it's like chocolate spam it's
bomb i want one of those well the metal
tin i remember the metal
oh my god the rabbit yeah the
light-skinned rabbit
the light-skinned rabbit we can't have
them too dark we don't want our
daughters going on those side of the
tracks that's exactly what that was for
they made a light skinned rabbit what
the [ __ ] did you see a light round
rabbit ever just made them darker
i loved nesquik look at him
that's the kind of type of tattoo you
get when you're 18. yep yo did you [ __ ]
with strawberry quick
yes yes i just compared a strain of weed
to that the other day
it tasted just like it whoa just like
speaking of weed uh
stefan raquel is getting into the is in
the biz i know the guy that he was
talking to that was like this isn't real
turned out to be real and they're making
purple urkel yep
yeah purple urkel because it's been
around forever good [ __ ]
capitalize on your own name [ __ ]
i'm so happy for him i'm like yes yes
i'll sadly
do a review on [ __ ] purple article
please let me be there i want to be
there for the episode i love
oh my god he's got his own yeah when he
told me that i go oh okay maybe you guys
are real
but halfway through i'm like oh my god
you wanna have a meeting right here [ __ ]
sorry the guy sorry guy whoever you were
i don't remember his business associate
we'll just call him a business associate
okay what's the next one rapid fire
because this is the most non-rapid fire
ever if you and i actually had to open
rapid fire
one person would die and be one one of
us
not on purpose like an accident because
we're terrible with guns because we're
nice people
i am bad with guns i'm not gonna look
okay okay
uh mari put this one in i didn't see
that one this morning independence or
training day that's a
easy oh training day thursday i'm
thirsty you want a beer welcome to earth
that's all you get from that [ __ ]
independence movie though independence
day it's that
and into the yeah into the white house
thank you the peace stream to the white
house and randy quinn off
the training day you're like wow this is
a really great cop to
rot row yep row this is the worst cop
also
thank you training day for introducing
us to one of the most beautiful women
oh what is her [ __ ] name again daisy
fontes i will leave no worth
i will leave you here you just said
daisy fuentes and
there are spanish people everywhere
going ideos meo it's okay
daisy fuentes was tough it was not it
was it's that girl
she's in the movie with will smith
what's her [ __ ] mendez
eva mendes
i am not a lesbian but i would like to
get the center of that lollipop
[Laughter]
that movie i believe that was one of her
first roles yes
eva mendes wow i forgot about her and
and
ryan gosling should thank denzel why
for introducing us to her ryan gosling's
married to her
oh i have no idea yeah the guy from
drive you ever see driving i know who
ryan gosling is
that's her husband drive his son no
drive that's that's my type
what's your type what's your type the
type of a man who would beat the [ __ ]
out of a dude in elevator for looking at
me wrong just kidding i'm not trying to
attract that type of energy so that you
don't want that
i don't want that but i do want that but
just not like the full
bore ryan gosling drive but like
like drive light like safe drive
i want a nice white guy with two picks
in his teeth
that would beat somebody up if they
touched me there
i want drive light anything more than
that you're going my mom route
you might as well [ __ ] date a
convicted felon look at that picture
makes me not want his
jacket and drive marty can you see if he
could pull up the back of his jacket
that shit's bombing oh it's such a it's
a dope
japanese traditional jacket that
actually oh
look at that sick those types of jackets
actually came around
after the war it was they they created
those jackets and made them double-sided
to show the piece between japan and
america so you'd have the japanese side
to represent the japanese government and
then the american side to show the
american
government i just know it because i did
a uso tour there and i got a jacket and
a guy totally
probably told me a fake story and i
bought it and and now i own a 400
jacket fake history he sold you yeah
do we need to do a show called fistery i
was talking about everybody you ever
banged
my we'd be going we'd have 10 seasons
yours i think yours would
teeter out after one season mine would
be going for 10.
okay go go go no no no i think i think i
think we got him
oh no we did it i see him okay i see him
i see him oh that's so spam
do it do it pennywise or chucky ugh oh
[ __ ] hate
oh god like which one i like more yeah
which one do you like more
oh [ __ ] cause you like horror movies i
[ __ ] hate them so much
we started the conversation with this
that's what we were talking about
mr photographic memory hey what did
strategically just forgetting
pennywise or chucky like that i have to
like more yes
movie the movie and part ones only
okay man i'm gonna
not the new painting i'm gonna say
chucky cause i wanna be on his good side
because that [ __ ] still haunts
me
i was scared till he's like 18 years old
i i would jump from my doorway to my bed
because i was afraid there was he was
under my bed what
i talked to ryan sickler about i know i
used to jump from my [ __ ] room all
the way over to my bed so he went
snacks he wouldn't snatch my ankles out
i thought i'd just do the same thing
yep i would do the same thing i'd
memorize everything in my room uh go
and then i'd walk and jump as far as i
could you did the same [ __ ] didn't you
every yep you memorized your room goal
when i say
i used to do that [ __ ] like i was taking
pictures of the kids you said i would
memorize my room and shuffle it
that's where my photograph memory comes
from scared of chucky hey you can't
remember what i said an hour ago but you
know where your [ __ ]
laundry basket is yep i do
[ __ ] chucky chucky freaked me out and
the man who
whose soul was inside of him you were
the same person
that's what scared me wasn't bruce
willis the voice of it
couldn't be because then every time
bruce willis would talk he would scare
the [ __ ] out of me
i felt like it was bruce willis i could
be making this up no it's damn
oh my god package they move
tickets out that part when he starts
oh and his face gets rubbery oh god oh
when he starts
when he starts to melt oh when he's
that's how he screams too oh who was his
voice marty i thought it was bruce
willis i probably just
i've had such a lady boner for bruce
willis get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here no way
i did not know that [ __ ] excuse me did
we just are you
serious no way mark hamill he's getting
paid through oh wait no are we reading
this wrong
i'm gonna have a heart attack you just
scared the [ __ ] out of me i thought i
thought i thought i can't watch any kind
of star wars anymore oh my god
no mark hamill's not in chucky are they
doing a new chucky
are there so much news and information
happening oh a new one
they're doing a new one oh gross you
know what
i'm not mad at it but the bride of
chucky really [ __ ] me up why do we
have to give him a love life
friday chucky made me not be as afraid i
just was so mad i'm like funnier
can't love have its own lane we've got
the notebook we don't need to make
chucky the notebook
well it was like a true bro i mean uh
natural born killers
oh it was like natural porn killers the
only murderers in every movie you've
ever rooted for
that's right it's like jim henson meets
natural porn killers
i respect that reference i still think
adding love to a horror movie
where chucky was just a murderous doll
[ __ ] it up for me
but jennifer tilly's voice was very
she's so cool fun to listen to so cool
with [ __ ] liar liar she was great
voice for that
she was great in liar liar she was so
tired she's so good so tight
she was so just you seeing you did you
describe women as so tight like good but
immediately i was like how do you know
that i know her how do you know she was
so tight
i have history with jennifer tilly oh my
god you have history with her history
can we do a segment called fistery not
now marty's definitely peeing now you
see those stance yo marty you really do
look like you're pissing you guys
i would think with such a nice setup
you'd have a [ __ ] bathroom but
marty's just pissing in a basket
guys it's like a three-hour episode
here's nothing i can do oh how long
we've been talking
wait how long we've been talking 250. i
mean
what is this rogan am i in austin
did you guys have me drive to austin yep
he's illegal you better get arrested
i saw on that list full house or saved
by the bell
full house you saved by the bed and see
that all day long marty how dare you
full house because i wasn't even getting
fingered yet if i had been getting
fingered
saved by the bell all day would have
been better because mario lopez was
there yeah with those dimples
he's another person that is awesome he
has an age
i said that the other day he drinks
baby's blood i [ __ ] hope not
i hope so cause then i have an answer i
have a solution
are you kidding me i would be the best
babysitter i'm like okay i don't know
where the kid is
get him in the ass you wouldn't notice i
show up looking like mrs doubtfire i
leave looking like
dakota fanning like i don't know what
happened yo we just got on the [ __ ]
adrenal chrome blood
he crawled away you know two years old
just crawled right into he said he'd be
back he got an uber and he's gone
yeah he said he had to go walk the dog i
know you don't have a dog but he said he
was gonna go
oh my god i hope he's just really really
good jeans
because i love him no there's no good
jeans he [ __ ]
runs like eight miles in the morning
every morning every morning
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] if i could be asleep
and somebody moved my body i'd be
[ __ ] with that
but i would not weaken a bernie style
have you met your match
has there anyone nope i've never met
another human in my life that knows all
the movies i'm like
uh weekend at bernie's just rewatched it
the other day does it hold up
what kind of [ __ ] don't realize
this man is dead what kind of
[ __ ] don't realize how
dark that movie is he's a dead body and
they want to have so much fun at his
house
and they want the raise and the
promotion from his their boss
that they pretend that he's alive that's
that this should be the white supremacy
movie this movie's just about to
literally take a man's life away
just to use him for money
they took his land he may be dead but
he's the life of the party
what a good slogan wrote this movie
doesn't understand
human decomposition right there's you
know there's three or two
he's gonna compose how they keep him so
fresh
i will never know because at the end of
part one he was he disappeared
i mean just the logistics alone it's
like a family guy
you tell me weed isn't a good drug where
somebody got together with a
with their best friend was like yo you
know it'll be really funny
is if two dudes were like dire straight
and then they killed their boss but kept
them around for the party
so that they could like fake everybody
out and they ended up making the movie
you know what it's probably a real story
behind that oh i'm
sure that's probably working i bet you
there's some real [ __ ] going on
there definitely was some rich dude and
they killed him and probably had a party
at the house and then
make it look like no he's here he's here
and then they rock put him to bed
yeah but at least they made it for our
viewing pleasure that's just funny when
he's walking and dancing
no matter what it's still funny guy did
you ever watch my father the hero
no with gerard depardieu no
oh my god maybe it's a chick flick
but look who's he looks like [ __ ]
shrek
that [ __ ] looks like fabio and
shrek look at that face gerard de pardue
looks like he eats steroids for
breakfast he's
only in his face uh uh what was it happy
gilmore
uh when fully he shoots in the head from
double07 with a nail gun yes
yes and that's katherine but it's
katherine heigl
wow she's from grey's anatomy i know i
know you're talking about holding
27 dress oh not yeah she's 27 dresses
holy [ __ ]
is her and she was she's a child right
there baby okay
what about never seen this the
professional
of course talked about the other day um
why was that little girl
coming on to him so strong sexually
advanced you know
weird they there was something i watched
for the director
where everybody there was an
uncomfortable set
that it's way more way more suggestive
there's deleted
there's [ __ ] that's not in the in the
final i just i just compared josh josh
wolfe the other day
to gary oldman in this movie memory
takes the pills and goes
that's josh's mushrooms and that's why i
told him the first time i met him five
seconds in and go
you ever seen the professional that's
you he there it is
that's how josh takes shrooms that's
josh look
we have to make a clip of this that's
josh is like gary oldman from the
professional
look that is so funny that's him and
then he's going to be funny after
that is hilarious that's him get
prepping for dopeziola
yep that's it was unusual that's right
this is dope as usual no that was but
it's still
the first time i ever met josh she took
too many streams i had to say i don't
know it's on camera
it's on film it's on his page him
popping it in no
him getting too [ __ ] up and he went
off the deep end what did he do
nothing i could see it in his eyes that
he needed to be saved
how did you feel because i could see
that he was about to start having a
panic attack really
remember you should you should watch it
it's on camera
it's a highlight first time i ever met
him you when you did his high life
oh no he got so i could see it on his
face that he wasn't coming back if i
didn't reel him back in how did you reel
him back in
calm down it's all right you'll oh you
had to say that yeah like calm down
we're all good
oh my god that dude he's the greatest
is that just the greatest person ever
that [ __ ] is hilarious he's got
the biggest heart
he's cool as [ __ ] he's just one of the
greatest people on earth
truly he's just such a beam he's an
artist as well
did he ever show you the picture i drew
of him do you know how to draw
oh i'm an artist you really do not i'm
an artist he is so bad at it
and he's better than i am and i love his
face as he tries to draw
mushrooms and compare to the celebrity
it's it's bad amazing he draws like
somebody who's been locked in a room his
whole life and never saw like
never put his foot on grass he draws
like somebody who's
drawing things he's never seen yes
that's how i draw i draw i don't know if
i don't know if if he put he might have
put
it up on his page marty but i don't know
because he was so excited about it he
made me send it to him so he could show
it to bethany
i'll i'll send it to you afterwards
because it's it's quite a work of art
truly that's such a rant we just talked
about the professional when we were
talking about something else
[ __ ] up man the professional is [ __ ]
up it's a [ __ ] up movie but it's so i
hate the ending we should have a show
called tangents
just link i used to do that as a kid
you're doing it as an adult yeah
as a board no i just like what do
you've made a career doing it yeah
that's
my whole life i call it rant city
because rant city [ __ ]
rant city yeah we've created like 10
shows
we have and we need one that's gonna get
us [ __ ] paid and on the air
none of them are going to be arable
because they're all inappropriate
where's the where's the speed round is
there more that's it no that's it
i didn't know you're gonna be so [ __ ]
good with it if you if i knew you're
gonna be so good that would have done
more
now you know i do know now and if you
don't know
there you go but you over here picking
tupac and you over here
i know look look i should be biggie
because i'm from new york
i should be and you should be tupac
right just
commandments is just too strong it's too
strong for me to pick two parts because
i love two parts
that beat the ten crack the production
on ten crack command
commandments is it's just
it's on par it's so good we're over here
in marty's realm right now
life after death it definitely goes down
as one of the
greatest albums of all time so good
it's such a great album the only bad
thing my mom did was tell me biggie
smalls sucked
because she was such a tupac fan so i
didn't listen to dolls 21.
and when i heard it go i text my mom
immediately
travis he didn't tell you drugs no i was
hiding him from her
she was she was on him too you can't
really hide music's a little bit harder
to hide
but you still could have hit it but
that's crazy that's like me with
certain things in life like just finding
it late yeah i found it
really like butt sex that's like i found
that around 21. i was like oh where have
you been hiding little fella
aren't you delightful i'm sorry
i'm not sorry history baby i'm sorry
i love something they sound good up here
that's how i think too i sounded good
when i had it
here when it got out here
oh my god i can't [ __ ] believe we've
been talking for three hours three hours
well
we it's probably good that we didn't do
too much up front
but we started talking like this it's
been more than three hours
yeah it's been like i've been here it's
it's 2022. covet is gone
there's a new disease we have a new
president kofi has
has mutated 10 times [ __ ] and now it's a
human
it's called ron jeremy everybody ron
jeremy is a human coven
here we go again you trying to end and
we're going into another i know
okay we're gonna we can't we almost
forgot to start we can't forget to end
okay okay
how do we do it all right ready yep
no i'm just kidding we don't do [ __ ] we
just stare off until
everyone decides that they don't want to
watch anymore
oh my god i forgot to drink water did we
say goodbye
oh yeah i do sometimes do you have like
any sponsors to thank
i do that [ __ ] separate because i don't
like doing that [ __ ]
yo i just noticed your producer's
sneakers those are so [ __ ] tight
i saw while we were sitting here are
they the ones that you take off
oh you did it oh dan did this can i send
you my sneakers
she did this background sick right
what's her name deanna deanna damn
deanna
girl marty this is the one you hired
exactly yes i remember when all this was
being done
and i i saw i saw your page you're very
talented
very talented crazy drawings i can't
trust [ __ ]
i wish i took 11 years of arts class i'm
a pure artist i'm
i'm i'm i'm basquiat i'm a singer i'm a
professional my [ __ ] is so tight
i'm everything um every you guys are
gonna have such an expensive episode
i'll just stop singing
you're okay okay we have to end wasn't
that in a [ __ ] shampoo commercial too
i was just thinking of that commercial
yeah i was thinking that song like two
days ago
in the commercial you know what else is
[ __ ] up
basquiat just sold a painting for 43
million dollars
there are dead [ __ ] that are
richer than us
whoa his family could be crackheads just
living off their [ __ ] dead relative
would you rather be a poor like
regular person or a rich crackhead rich
crackhead yeah it'd be more fun
oh my god could you imagine the crack if
i
liked it i'd have a lot of it can you
imagine the alternate universes you'd be
living in the alternate realities
so much bliss do you remember an hour
ago when we tried to end
i uh i was there i was there for a
minute
i was here i'm gonna stop singing bust
out in song i do it all the time but i
gotta stop because it's i do it so
[ __ ] like i do it all the time and
it's how i talk
if someone says or says something that
reminds me i sing it
[ __ ] in the office you just can't not
sing i love it
what if we both just stopped talking
wait are you an office fan
i meant i was just trying to help you
end it i love the office
okay i've been watching i stopped i
haven't watched it for three months two
and a half months and then i watched it
two nights ago
you're describing it like it's cocaine i
even said like i've been clean for
[ __ ] two and a half months
it's so i watched every day funny all
day every [ __ ] day my favorite thing
about the office is ricky gervais
talking [ __ ] about
um uh what's his name steve carroll
steve carrell for years
wait they're if you like the uk office
or the yeah the man who created the
i'm saying you like the uk office or the
us office which one are we talking about
here i like both but you know the uk was
it oh gee
yeah it's it's it's that's and i think
that's why ricky talks [ __ ]
because he knows the office office is
just so took off
it's my favorite show of all time you
have to when you get home
google ricky gervais talking [ __ ] and
there's so
many award shows where he oh yeah she
introduces him
the other me yeah yeah but ricky gervais
is on another level of being a [ __ ]
badass
when he [ __ ] on everybody at the oscars
it made me
it was like a presidential
in the crowd you can see addre go he
didn't give a [ __ ]
he didn't care that's one of the
greatest last time videos
the compilation on youtube is nine
minutes and it's the best nine minutes
that's right it is it's just his pieces
it's almost as long as crystalia's
so-called apology video
pl cue kirby enthusiasm
and you turn into a cartoon with the
choice
i love that show so [ __ ] much oh we
just talked about the crystal episode
and then something happened we're like
yo we can't post this episode because it
took
we talked about too many topical things
and we didn't edit it two weeks ago
so we had a whole crystalline thing and
me and mari talked about it what are we
good what about all the [ __ ] we talked
about today i feel like we did 10
episodes
no i'm saying because we talked about
because i was talking about like
time-specific things yeah
and we [ __ ] forgot to edit the video
so you know what let's trash that one
for now
we'll wait on it even though it's gonna
get worse how long we wait but uh
we talked about the crystallia thing and
i told mario i texted him like did you
see crystal
yeah is on the internet and i didn't
know who he was i saw him at the comedy
store and go yo this [ __ ] is
kind of funny
and then i saw what happened went oh
[ __ ] and i knew about everything that
happened then i saw the apology thing
and i go
wait you're just mad you got caught
because all that said was that was a
well i'm not going to say something
sorry apology i'm not going to say sorry
but
i'm going to let you know that i was
there when i wanted to say sorry but i
said it in different
i'm sorry that you guys forced me into a
situation that i took advantage of
yes it's a [ __ ] up scenario
it sucks because it's like
i want a like you so much man i want to
like you so much
but if you lived in like a neighborhood
you would get stomped out already you're
the guy that has to leave now
and it's like i don't know what's going
on behind closed doors but like your
your girl and your a baby he's got a
girlfriend
uh exactly cue curb your enthusiasm
thing song
again yo all right that makes it so much
worse okay
i had no idea i wish everybody best of
luck yeah i wish i hope
i'll love wish you the best of luck i
just everybody in life damn that's all
of us
that sucks a lot yeah but it's okay
remember when we ended four hours ago
i remember something about it number one
don't even start with these so is that a
new [ __ ]
that's what i say zone zone zone
what it's don't but i hear you if for
some reason it sounds better
doesn't it it does it has more more
authority in it
i think i should put it on a shirt zone
zone
you got oh my god get the [ __ ] out of
here
it's a pop eight seconds later it was so
so much longer it was good it was a long
time later on a shirt and it's gonna
have dots around
we got it oh sorry we gotta end this
[ __ ] i'm gonna stop i gotta stop
sorry guys i will stop this bye thank
you so much for coming today
i really appreciate it where can we find
you are you uh is it jasmine pools on
every single thing
yes jesse may plus on every single thing
except for one thing because somebody
took over one of my things i don't want
to encourage it
um sharp tongue podcast sharp tongue
podcast yes
on all streaming platforms all streaming
platforms and
for your listeners we are giving a
um a discount on
the the adaptogens that i drink
and so if they watch the mushrooms every
day
oh what'd you think i was gonna say
you're gonna say something a discount on
this dick
oh the one time where i normally would
you're like here she goes the dick joke
and i'm trying to
get back uh we're giving your followers
a discount on my dick
i'm gonna give you followers
you sell the stuff that you drink let's
get back into this
go to mudwater.com it's called mudwater
for real
mudwater.com mudwater.com yeah and if
you put jessie maymud we're gonna give
you guys a discount jessie maymud yeah
that's it m-a-m-a-e though right
j-e-s-s-i-m-a-e-m-u-d
jesse may mud and we're going to give
y'all discount and you can have some
mushrooms in your
tea all right well
they're they're gonna be so happy well i
thought i was getting dick
i got these mushroom tips are they the
tips of
dick yeah we gotta stop
on all socials on all socials it'll be
linked in the description
stalk me in life just find me in life
yes just in real life at the coffee shop
sharp tongue podcast my marketing
partner always feels hilarious because i
never promote myself well
that's just highlighting i have a
hilarious podcast stop
i bought the word win uh
yeah the [ __ ] i bought it i got it i
forget when it was my hashtag a couple
years
i made up and 2012 is hilarious we're
going to court
we're h-i-l-a-r-r-y to court us it was a
hashtag i made
i used to do it because i used to make
funny week stuff
get the [ __ ] out of you just when i saw
go what
i have a [ __ ] series on youtube it
was called hilarious well we need to go
to court holy [ __ ] i don't use that [ __ ]
uh it's i haven't done oh my
god that is [ __ ] crazy i've been
using it for so many
[ __ ] years are we the same person
that is awesome
i just felt it with larry that's it
larry hi larry
like l-a-r-r-i-l-a why oh yeah but
that's weird that's awesome we're very
very similar people
yeah i think i got it like five years
ago
how awesome and then i was like i had to
use it so i just did a podcast and i i
have a dispensary
and we filmed this and recorded in the
description
yeah nice yeah and josh is on that i
think josh is pot and parenting i think
that's his episode and parenting
yeah who shot jfk
yeah how could pop me who shot jfk
how can pot improve your sex who shot
jfk
in the middle of all those things that's
such a such a
toner like we're gonna have themed
episodes like oh
it's all about weed
also cut to us ending six hours ago
sorry we stopped six hours we did it we
did it's now did i say things i needed
to say yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
shut down podcast mudwater.com that's
the website notmudwater.com mudwater.com
and that's discount on the mushrooms yes
and the mushrooms you drink the [ __ ]
every day for
every single morning it replaced my
coffee coffees to like
bug me out i don't know if you can i
don't [ __ ] coffee i can't okay you and i
are brains
okay i hate it and so i needed something
else and i found them and now we work
together they're amazing
they do some really cool stuff good [ __ ]
yeah their product i'll get you some if
you want to try some
[ __ ] yeah i want to try it and you can
put some mushrooms in it
i have some mushrooms i do it's so good
i'll try i have some micro doses at my
house and then you'll be online shopping
all day long it's good
it's good for the economy online shop on
zillow those things i can't afford
me too yes i look at it go well maybe
i'll have 16 million dollars
all the time 13 000 square feet sounds
right
yeah i do it all the [ __ ] i did it
last night i've been doing that for
months
i stopped recently because i moved i
stopped recently because i renewed my
lease and went uh
i stopped recently because i need this
is
i need motivation in six months and then
i'll start looking yeah yeah yeah and
i'll go i'll make 16
million 15 is easy i want doors to open
like this me
[ __ ] i want my damn living room to
open into my pool
yeah so i can slide into my pool did you
see that video of the pool that's in the
house and you can go through the wall
and go into the outdoor
pool i'll [ __ ] die under there i will
suck a dick for that kind of house
any girl saying that she she wouldn't
they already dropped
whoever lives there does let me live my
life
bye god let's let's we all right we have
to end on that
thank you so much appreciate it on all
platforms guys will be linked in the
description
once again thank you for listening to
the dope as usual podcast thank you for
listening to this longest outro ever
yesterday paluso thank you so much i'm
gonna go smoke this and think of you
thank that's all i ever wanted i just
didn't want to not be able to find my
house but now
you'll be good i'll be good all right
thank you guys so much for watching
have a dope ass day wow what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] just happened to
us i don't know but i tried to end that
[ __ ] so do we just become your best
friends
i have a sword somewhere here i swear to
god do you want to go to karate in the
garage
dude is that what they say do you want
to go do karate in the garage
[Laughter]
if you're here you watch the episode in
full and i know it was probably long as
[ __ ] so shout out to you first off we're
watching it
guys this is our post show ad read thank
you so much to stereo app you guys we've
been talking about it non-stop
stereo app click the link in our
description it's on our twitter it's on
our
instagram everything stereo app is
basically our live chat
to each other marty i marty and i marty
and rosie
me and rosie doesn't matter who i'm with
we can do a live chat you can send
messages in it's live
interaction if you have questions you
can't get through on comments go to
stereo app
it's [ __ ] free don't be a [ __ ] all
right it's [ __ ] free go download that
guys every time you click that it gets
us paid if you click that link
and download and follow us from our link
marty and i get paid more it's more
opportunity we're trying to do two
episodes a week
if we can hire two more people we can
bust out two episodes a week so that's
why it really helps out
i'm just like i said i'm always going to
be transparent with you guys we do
everything for free so
now it's time to get [ __ ] paid
thank you guys so much shout out to
[Music]
stereo
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
bye